[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Faites pas les timides. Nous sommes en
direct. Nous sommes sur une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Yve
Brchet, est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Alors, je
m'appelle Yve Bréchet. Je suis euh
scientifique métallurgiste, membre de
l'Académie des Sciences. J'ai fait une
bonne partie de ma carrière dans le
milieu académique. J'ai été haut
commissaire énergie atomique entre 2012
et 2018. Et depuis 2018, je suis
directeur scientifique de la compagnie
Saint-Gobin, donc à la fois scientifique
et industrielle.
Monsieur Louis Galois, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Absolument. Je suis né dans à Monta, ce
qui veut dire que je suis attaché à la
province et je suis j'ai été fait j'ai
fait une carrière de fonctionnaires
avant de rentrer dans l'entreprise et
j'ai dirigé un certain nombre
d'entreprises.
Euh les deux plus emblématiques, c'est
la SNCF d'un côté et Airbus de l'autre.
Il y en a eu quelques autres mais c'est
cela. Et maintenant, je suis coprésident
de la fabrique de l'industrie qui est un
sig tank que je partage avec je partage
la coprésidence avec
Pierre André Charlodard, l'ancien patron
de Saint-Gobin. Donc nous sommes dans
une ambiance Saint-Gobin.
Bon ce soir, on va se faire une
interview tonton Flinguer industrie
énergie qui est-ce qui veut commencer
pour me faire le bilan de la situation
de la France et les perspectives
industrielles énergétiques et qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour réindustrialiser
la France ?
qui commence. Je veux bien commencer au
fond puisque c'est une question sur
l'industrie.
La situation de la France, c'est une
situation
qui n'est partagée que par les
États-Unis et la Grande-Bretagne.
C'est-à-dire que nous sommes les trois
pays dans le monde qui se sont
désindustrialisés le plus vite et le
plus fort.
La production industrielle représente à
peu près 9 à 10 % du PIB
et on a à peu près stabilisé cette
situation depuis
une dizaine d'années, mais la chute a
été d'une brutalité extrême. Les
conséquences sont claires. comme
d'emploi de commerce extérieur,
rupture de des territoires
et
profondément
l'idée pour les Français d'un certain
déclassement
et d'un déclin. Je pense que le cette
mentalité décliniste qui prospère en
France est largement d à la
désindustrialisation.
Voilà la situation telle qu'elle est.
Elle n'est partagée que par la
Grande-Bretagne et les États-Unis et qui
ont les États-Unis l'alternative des
technologies et de la Silicone Vallée.
La Grande-Bretagne, elle a son marché
financier.
La France
elle se trouve un peu dépourvue et je
pense que c'est le moment pour elle de
réfléchir et surtout de se donner une
perspective.
Je crois que nous manquons de
perspective
et cette perspective pour moi c'est
c'est de faire de la France un pays de
production.
Nous avons perdu l'esprit de producteur.
Nous étions un pays d'ingénieurs. Nous
ne le sommes plus tout à fait. Et nous
avons absolument besoin de de retrouver
ce goût de créer, de produire. Vous
connaissez le renoncement de
Saint-Pierre
et moi je sortirai de ce monde où
l'action n'est pas sœur du rêve.
Yve euh pourquoi on a décroché d'un coup
là ? C'était un trou d'air, un manque de
portance, un manque de cap, un manque de
stratégie, un manque de vision où on est
gouverné par des
bras cassés.
Alors, sur le point de vue de la de
l'industrialisation ou de la
réindustrialisation, parce que moi je me
pose dans la je me mets dans la
perspective de savoir qu'est-ce qu'on va
reconstruire, euh je pense que ce qu'il
faut, on résout pas un problème si on en
prend pas d'abord conscience et j'ai
l'impression qu'on est en train d'en
prendre conscience et que ceux qui en
ont pris conscience, c'est plutôt la
base et les électeurs et les citoyens
que les gens qui les dirigent.
Donc, mais je pense que cette conscience
est présente maintenant. Alors, elle est
pas forcément déclinée dans ces
différents aspects. Je pense qu'une
industrie,
c'est grosso modo quelque chose qui
prend de la matière, qui en fait des
produits avec du travail et de
l'énergie. Alors ça ça nous donne
quelles sont les conditions pour pouvoir
avoir une industrie. Les conditions,
c'est d'avoir une énergie, une énergie
pas chère, une énergie disponible, une
énergie stable. C'est d'avoir un outil
industriel qui permet de transformer de
la matière en produit et c'est d'avoir
les compétences pour le faire. Et une
des caractéristiques de la France dans
les disons les 30 dernières années,
c'est un peu comme ça que je vois les
choses, c'est qu'on a réussi à détruire
à la fois l'outil industriel et la
volonté de faire. On a réussi à détruire
en partie en grande partie des atouts
qu'on avait du côté de la ressource
d'énergie. On n pas de ressources en
matière. Donc ça veut dire que pour
pouvoir réaliser quelque chose et bien
il faut vraiment avoir l'outil
industriel et l'énergie. Et la chose qui
me semble encore la plus profonde en
terme de drame structurel, c'est la
destruction du savoir, de la
connaissance.
La chute du niveau de dans le domaine
des sciences et des techniques a
commencé par l'école primaire. Je veux
dire, pour moi, on reconstruit un pays
quand on commence par reconstruire
convenablement la formation et pas
simplement la formation, mais aussi le
goût des enfants pour faire. Et je pense
que c'est tout ça qui est derrière la
prise de conscience. Il va falloir que
on décline ça en le déclinant de la même
manière, non pas en pleurant sur les
renversés, mais en le déclinant de la
même manière, disant "Bah, on fait quoi
maintenant ?" Et moi, je suis d'un
naturel optimiste et je pense que la
génération montante prend à la fois
conscience du problème et commence à
comprendre ce qu'il faudrait faire.
Louis, l'apprentissage quand on est
grand patron de boîte, l'apprentissage
le fait de pouvoir engager des
apprentis, de faire perdurer le savoir,
la connaissance et la transmission
auprès des des gamins qui viennent dans
les grandes entreprises. On peut le voir
aussi chez les soudeurs dans les
centrales nucléaires, on peut le voir
sur tout un tas de choses. Un conseil
pour les apprentis qui nous regardent
maintenant et un conseil pour ceux qui
veulent taxer
la formation d'apprenti.
Ils veulent pas taxer, ils veulent
réduire les subventions. Oui, c'est
l'inverse. Mais enfin euh c'est vrai que
l'apprentissage c'est quelque chose qui
euh euh manquait à la France. Moi, je
ayant dirigé Airbus, je passais la
moitié de mon temps en Allemagne et en
Allemagne, l'apprentissage est une
extrêmement présent et il est témoin en
en France. Il y a eu au cours des années
récentes un progrès assez substantiel,
mais cet apprentissage a surtout
concerné l'apprentissage après le bac et
je pense que maintenant il faut regarder
l'apprentissage avant le bac. Moi, j'ai
une préoccupation, ce sont les lycées
professionnels. Les lycées
professionnels sont des des des lycées
que les gens ne choisissent pas. les les
jeunes ne choisissent pas d' lycée
professionnel ou c'est rare. Ils le
subissent parce que au fond leur dit
vous n'êtes pas dans vous ne pouvez pas
suivre la voie générale, vous allez dans
le lycée professionnel et il faut faire
du lycée professionnel une filière
d'excellence. Et je suis persuadé que
on a on a fait une une erreur. Il y
avait 4 ans d'études dans lycée
professionnel. On a ramené ça à 3 ans.
C'est bien qu'on a pratiquement réduit
la période d'apprentissage. Je crois
qu'il faut revenir à 4 ans et que il y
ait une année entière qui soit concer
qui soit consacrée à l'apprentissage. Et
je pense que euh comme le disait Yve, ça
va nous ça va remettre les jeunes dans
l'idée de de de produire. Alors, on peut
aussi voir que l'apprentissage ne porte
pas uniquement sur les aspects de
industriel, hein, mais il y a des
filières qui sont à mon avis moins
intéressantes parce que elles débouchent
moins sur des métiers. Les apprentis
dans le domaine industriel, ils sont
sûrs de trouver du boulot et ils sont
sûrs de trouver du boulot à mon avis
plus intéressant que ce qu'il trouverait
ailleurs. Nous avons à convaincre les
jeunes que l'industrie, c'est pour eux
une solution. positive, créatrice.
Par exemple, il y a pas d'écologie sans
industrie. Toutes les questions
écologiques entraînent des aspects de
production, que ça soit pour l'énergie
que disait Yve, mais les batteries, euh
le recyclage,
euh la santé, l'agroalimentaire.
Donc sur tous ces sujets qui sont liés à
la transition écologique, on a besoin
d'industrie et je pense qu'il faut que
les jeunes le le touche du doigt et rien
n'est mieux que
d'avoir que l'apprentissage.
On peut d'ailleurs se demander s'il faut
pas commencer plus tôt, s'il faut pas,
comme le disait Yve, que dès l'école
primaire, on fasse toucher aux enfants,
aux jeunes la matière pour que ils
s'aperçoivent que la transformation de
la matière et rien de plus beau.
Il voulait rebondir,
je peux rebondir là-dessus. Je pense que
cette question de l'apprentissage est
pas du tout euh euh c'est pas du tout un
détail. C'est quelque chose qui est un
état d'esprit. Moi, je suis un grand
adepte de la perméabilité entre les
entre les les communautés. Euh et
l'apprentissage, c'est en principe une
perméabilité entre le monde industriel
et le monde éducatif. c'est de dire euh
pour que les gens puissent trouver leur
place dans l'industrie et y construire
une carrière, bien il faut aussi qu'ils
aient une formation, une formation qui
est pas que la formation pratique mais
qui est aussi la formation pratique. Là,
je vais donner quelques exemples. Euh je
suis natif de Clermontferrand, donc
plusieurs générations de Michelin,
c'est vers l'Auvergne, ça non ? C'est
ça. C'est plusieurs générations de
Michelin. Il y avait
il y avait une une à Clermontferrand une
école qui s'appelait la mission qui
était d'une école technique. La raison
Michelin avait créé la mission c'est
date des années 30 cette chose avait
créé la mission parce que il n'avait pas
le vivier de technicien ou de d'ou de
technicien c'est qui qui per qui était
nécessaire à son entreprise. Mais une
chose qui est intéressante c'est qu'il
formait 10 fois plus de personnes que le
nombre de personnes dont ils avaient
besoin. C'est-à-dire qu'on créé un
vivier de gens. Alors évidemment ils
sont ils se gardaient les meilleurs, ça
va s'en dire, mais on créé un vivier de
gens qui pouvaient irriguer tout un
tissu industriel et pas simplement le
cas de le cas de Michelin. Et je pense
que ce qu'on est en train de voir par
exemple avec ce que fait EDF, avec ce
qu'ils appellent l'université du
nucléaire, c'est très mal nommé ça
université du nucléaire parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est uniquement au
niveau des écoles d'ingénieur et des et
du doctorat. Non, c'est au niveau des
techniciens, c'est au niveau des gens de
métier et je crois que ça c'est vrai
c'est vraiment essentiel. Alors
maintenant, j'ai un autre aspect. qui
est euh je pense qu'il faut aussi penser
l'apprentissage au niveau de la
formation des ingénieurs, que ça soit
dans les écoles ou dans les universités.
Et je tire ça de deux aspects. Euh quand
j'enseigne au Canada, dans
l'amphithéâtre où j'enseigne, il y a
toujours des gens qui viennent de
l'industrie et qui font une année au
milieu de leur de leur formation et au
milieu de leur de leur carrière. Ils
font une année pour se former en plus.
et c'est complètement perçu comme
quelque chose de très positif par leurs
employeurs. Et le résultat, c'est d'une
part que évidemment pour un prof, c'est
à bonheur parce que ça veut dire il y a
quelqu'un dans la salle qui est capable
de vous dire là vous déconnez, c'est pas
du tout comme ça que ça se passe. Donc
on apprend des tas de choses. Mais une
deuxième chose qui est intéressante,
c'est que les jeunes qui sont dans la
salle, ils sont en contact direct avec
des gens qui pratiquent le métier que
bientôt ils vont faire. Donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a une perméabilité entre
les générations à ce niveau-là qui est
quelque chose qui est absolument
essentiel. Donc je pense alors il y a il
y a des formations d'ingénieurs qui se
font par apprentissage, par alternance
et moi j'ai coutume de dire que la
formation classique des ingénieurs en
France c'est un héritage direct de la
formation des mandarins en Chine. Ça a
ses avantages et ça a ses inconvénients.
La fondation la formation des ingénieurs
par alternance c'est quelque chose qui
est beaucoup plus proche de disons de la
formation des maîtres artisans par le
Tour de France au Moyen-Âge. Et je pense
que les deux ont leur richesse et qu'il
faudrait être capable de faire coexister
les deux. Et je crois que c'est une des
conditions pour pouvoir reconstruire une
industrie. On ne reconstruira pas une
industrie si on n pas un socle de gens
compétents à tous les niveaux et qui ont
envie de faire, qui ont envie de
construire, qui ont envie de fabriquer
des choses. Il y a une il y a une école
qui que j'aime bien parce que justement
elle mélange tout à fait ça sont les
arts des métiers. Voilà,
les ingénieurs des arts et métiers sont
des gens qui savent ce que c'est que
produire, qui vont vers l'industrie.
Alors que beaucoup
des d'anciens élèves des des grandes
écoles plus les plus les plus côtés ne
vont pas vers l'industrie, ils vont vers
la banque, ils vont vers le ils vont
vers les les cabinets de conseil et
cetera et ils sont attirés par
l'épaisseur de la moquette et et
et l'épaisseur du salaire. Et puis en
plus, on se lève plus tard, on se couche
plus tôt, enfin bon, ça a beaucoup
d'avantages. Et je les les les gaz,
c'estàd les élèves de des arts et
métiers, eux, ils viennent dans la
production, ils viennent dans les usines
et ils aiment ça.
Ah bah c'est des vrais ingénieurs, c'est
pas des ingénieurs PowerPoint ça. C'est
les ingénieurs PowerPoint. Bien vu. Bon
là, on a fait le le on a essayé de
combler le fossé intergénérationnel pour
motiver en fait les les gamins à
redresser le pays, à trouver du boulot.
Et bon, maintenant on va passer à le
constat de est-ce qu'il y a un pilote
dans l'avion, le constat de quel est le
milieu agressif où se trouve la France
avec les Allemands qui nous font des
crocheptes voir qui nous mettent des
couteaux dans le dos. Je vous vois
croiser les bras. Louis,
il faut faire ce constat. Faut pas
mettre les les lunettes roses. Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de l'Europe avec la
réglementation européenne d'arrêter les
véhicules thermique pour 2035 ?
comment ce comment la prospective
industrielle française est faite et
est-ce que les capitaines d'industrie
ont leurs mots à dire pour dire
maintenant oh là on se calme il y a des
boîtes qui calanchent qui font faillite
ça met des gens sur le carreaux est-ce
que les capitaines d'industrie
commencent à dire au gouvernement
maintenant il va falloir arrêter d'avoir
une clé de lecture digne d'un programme
télé avec les pages de l'horoscope à la
fin il faut avoir une vraie cellule de
prospective faire vraiment l'état de
l'art
de la situation et se donner un cap, une
action sœur du rêve. Le rêve, c'est
éviter que la France soit oblitérée par
une nonchalance à la tête. Qui est-ce
qui récupère la patate chaude ?
Je je crois que on a effectivement
besoin d'un cap et moi je suis pour la
planification.
Alors on va me dire ça y est gos plan.
Je vais vous dire François Berou
joker.
Ça y est, on est chaud.
Euh non, je suis pas planification. On
fait des tas de planification en France.
Il y a une planification de l'énergie,
la ce qu'on appelle la la la PPE. Il y a
une planification de la défense, loi
programmation sur la défense. Il y a une
loi de programmation sur la transition,
une une planification de la transition
écologique et cetera. Tout ça, il faut
bon c'est très gentil mais ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'il y ait un cadre commun
cohérent
après débat public parce que moi je
pense que c'est une affaire suffisamment
importante pour intéresser le pays et il
faut que le pays s'y intéresse. Vous
parlez de chef de d'industrie mais pas
uniquement. Il faut que leur salariés
aussi s'y intéressent. Il faut que les
syndicats s'y intéressent puis il faut
que tout le monde considère que c'est
quelque chose de très important. C'est
pour ça que je demande que cette
planification, elle a une forte
visibilité.
Oui. La France est en danger ou pas ?
Bah la France, elle est elle est ce
citer le général de Gaulle, ça
réconforte ce vieux pays qui va de
déclin en renouveau. Alors et bien le
renouveau est devant nous.
Ouais. Mais là ça ressemble un peu au
rebond du champ là. Non
non non non, je pense pas qu'il faille
désespérer d'un pays comme ça. Ça c'est
pas c'est c'est enfin c'est tout à fait
contraire à mon d'esprit. Moi, je suis
je suis pour être dans l'action, pour
que ça avance. Et pour avancer, je pense
qu'on a besoin d'un cap, on a besoin
d'une visibilité, on a besoin de savoir
où on va et et je pense en plus que ça
peut être un formidable projet
collectif. On fera pas rêver les
Français
par la réduction des déficits. C'est pas
quelque chose qui va les faire rêver. Il
faut évidemment réduire les déficits,
mais c'est pas ça qui va les faire
rêver. Moi, je crois qu'on peut les
entraîner sur un projet de de
réindustrialisation
parce qu'ils savent que c'est ça qui va
leur apporter l'emploi, c'est ça qui va
leur apporter la résistance par rapport
aux crises extérieures. C'est ça qui va
permettre au territoire de revivre parce
que l'industrie, elle est pas dans les
grandes villes, elle est elle est dans
les villes moyennes. Elle est elle est
là où les gens ont souffert de la
désindustrialisation.
Tout ça, je pense que les Français
peuvent le sentir.
Il faudra entraîner tout le monde et si
on y entraîne les jeunes, on aura gagné.
C'est ça le problème, l'enjeu entraîner
les jeunes là-dedans. Mais pour ça, il
faut il faut fixer le cap.
Alors, je suis aussi planificateur, mais
j'aurais tendance à dire que il y a
quelque chose qui est pire que de pas
faire, c'est de faire semblant. Donc ça
veut dire il faut vraiment le faire
sérieusement. Et le faire sérieusement,
ça veut dire quoi ? Une stratégie pour
moi, c'est quelque chose qui a à la fois
la vision d'ensemble, c'est ce qui lui
donne sa légitimité et qui a le souci du
détail, c'est ce qui lui donne sa
faisabilité. Si on oublie soit la vision
d'ensemble, soit le souci du détail, on
écrit des comptes de fait. Et je pense
que ça fait un moment qu'on écrit des
comptes de fait et qu'on va finir par le
payer très cher. Alors,
des exemples de compte de fé.
Ah bah toute la toute la programmation
sur l'énergie, ça compte de fait à
l'état pur ça.
Pourquoi ?
Oui, enfin c'est c'est fait carabos. On
laisse pas on laisse parler. C'est la fé
carabos. Non, mais je veux dire c'est un
compte de fait en ce sens qu'il y a pas
d'analyse des besoins, il y a pas
d'analyse des moyens, il y a pas
d'analyse des impacts et que tout ça
c'est juste fait pour en parler. Donc je
pense que pour moi la planification, le
prérequis de la planification ce que je
viens de dire sur ce qui est une
stratégie, c'est d'avoir une idée claire
que l'on veut faire quelque chose et pas
simplement en parler.
Et ça, je pense que c'est quand on parle
aux gens aux gens au vrai quoi, aux gens
que vous croisez dans la rue ou dans mon
village de Bourgogne, je veux dire c'est
quelque chose qui convain donc je pense
qu'il y a besoin d'une planification.
Alors maintenant, la planification faut
se dire la planification c'est Paul
Massé, c'est c'est Louis Armand, c'est
ça la planification. Alors je veux faire
chez personne donc je dirais pas ce que
ça aussi
c'est Bernard Rambert mais il était pas
commissaire commissaire au plan. Et donc
c'est je pense qu'il y a il y a quelque
chose qui est vraiment impératif, c'est
de cesser de faire semblant et de se
dire notre pays est dans une situation
grave, il est pas dans une situation
désespérée. Ce qui me fait penser que la
situation est grave mais pas désespérée.
C'est les expériences que j'ai quand je
vais faire des conférences aux
étudiants, quand je discute avec mes
paysans en Bourgogne parce que je vois
des gens qui fondamentalement ont un
solide bon sens. C'est des gens qui sont
pas suffisamment inscrits pour raisonner
de travers. Euh c'est des gens qui
aiment leur pays et qui ont envie de
construire des choses. Alors, je pense
que le grand défi qu'on a vis-à-vis de
la génération montante en laquelle je
crois euh moi le nombre d'étudiants qui
viennent me voir après une conférence en
disant "Bon mais c'est bien, mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Ce qui est juste
la bonne réaction." Moi je pense que le
grand défi qu'on a, c'est de les faire
de leur faire comprendre qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire.
On passe depuis ça fait 15 ans qu'on
narrête pas de dire au aux jeunes on va
tous mourir, bah merci, je suis au
courant. Ça va pas nous amener bien loin
tout ça. Par contre de dire le monde de
demain, c'est vous qui allez le
construire et si vous c'est vous qui
allez le construire avec les métiers que
vous avez, que ça soit le métier de
soudeur, que ça soit le métier de
chaudronnier ou que ça soit le métier
d'ingénieur, tout le monde peut et doit
y contribuer. Et moi, je suis persuadé
que ce message, on doit pouvoir le faire
passer et il doit pouvoir être reprimé.
Ça ça veut dire aussi une chose, c'est
qu'il faut que les gens comprennent que
c'est indispensable pour que le pays se
redresse, mais c'est aussi indispensable
pour que eux vivent bien dans ce pays.
Et ça, c'est aussi quelque chose qui est
important de se dire "On va pas vous
demander de travailler pour les autres,
on va vous demander de travailler pour
l'ensemble,
pour le pays."
Voilà. et et et pour et pour les
générations futures,
c'est il faut faut dire aux gens, vous
travaillez pour les générations futures.
Parce qu'actuellement,
on a un sentiment où les gens se
replient sur eux-mêmes,
quatre atonies émotionnelles et
intellectuelle
et qui se disent "Bon,
ça va pas, essayons de préserver ce que
nous avons." Moi, je pense que il faut
faire sortir les gens de cette coquille.
Il faut que les gens sachent sachent
qu'ils travaillent pour eux-mêmes, il
vient de le dire, et pour les
générations qui viennent. Parce que euh
la discussion sur les retraites, c'est
bien gentil, c'est nécessaire, utile.
Mais encore une fois, c'est pas ça qui
va entraîner les gens. Et il faut
entraîner les gens et je pense que c'est
possible. On l'a fait ailleurs. Moi,
j'ai j'ai une grande admiration pour un
pays comme la Corée.
Il y a il y a une planification, la
Corée du Sud.
La Corée du Nord très sympathique mais
c'est pas celle-là que je connais.
La Corée du Sud. La la la Corée du Sud
c'est un c'est c'est un pays où il y a
un dynamisme et un esprit collectif
communiste.
Je savais que vous étiez communiste.
Oui. La Corée du Sud je pas tout à fait
ça, mais c'est un pays à la fois très
dans l'économie ouverte,
confront exportant et cetera et qui en
même temps une planification. Et cette
planification, elle elle existe parce
que toutes les les forces de la viv de
la société y adhèrent. C'est ça qui est
important.
Je voudrais revenir sur Yve. Yve,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ils sont
pas suffisamment éduqués pour raisonner
de travers. Toi qui traînes un peu à
Polytechnique de temps en temps, ils
vont apprécier.
La phrase n'est pas de moi, elle est de
Montescux. Montes que disait "J'aime
bien discuter avec mes paysans, ils sont
pas suffisamment et ils sont pas
suffisamment savants pour raisonner de
travers." Je trouve ça très profond
parce que je veux dire, on peut avoir un
vernis et puis s'imaginer que ce vernis
vous donne une connaissance infuse de
tout. Euh et puis on peut se dire "Bon
ben je sais pas mais j'ai une raison et
cette raison doit me permettre de
comprendre ce qu'on me raconte. Ce que
je trouve absolument admirable, que je
n'ai jamais trouvé dans les ministères
aussi rarement, c'est de discuter avec
des gens et de les entendre me dire, "On
comprend pas, répète."
Euh et il me lâchait pas avant que j'ai
écrit, j'ai dit ce que je voulais dire
d'une manière compréhensible. Et ça
c'est très important. Je vais donner un
exemple que de ça que j'ai trouvé assez
fabuleux. C'était au moment où il y
avait eu un un début d'incendie à
Fenheim.
Euh et alors évidemment la preuve
d'Averte avait été travaillé accident
nucléaire ou quelque chose dans ce
genre. Il se trouve que j'habitais à
l'époque dans le 5e arrondissement, il y
avait un j'allais assez régulièrement
chez un bistroutier qui se trouvait être
un être un Auvernia bien sûr. Et il me
dit "Oui, je crois que vous êtes un peu
quelque chose dans l'énergie atomique."
J'étais au commissaire énergie atomique.
Je lui dis "Oui, un peu. C'est quoi
cette histoire d'accident à Fenheim ?"
Et donc je lui dis "Écoutez euh je sais
pas mais je vais me renseigner." Je
reviens le lendemain, je m'étais
renseigné auprès des gens de LAASN et il
m'avait dit grosso modo ce qui s'était
passé c'est
autorité de sûreté nucléaire ce qui
s'était passé c'est qu'il y avait eu un
début d'incendie à Fonim parce que il y
avait quelqu'un qui avait versé un bidon
d'eau oxygéné dans un dans un fus qui
était pas propre et qui comptait du
mazout évidemment ça avait pris feu
et mon bist trotier a eu ces deux
réflexions que j'ai trouvé extrêmement
saines et a dit ah bah c'est pas un
accident nucléaire chose qu' avait pas
compris le journaliste du monde. On a
soit dit en passant mais là
pas grand chose non plus
il peut-être pas envie de comprendre
mais la deuxième chose que la deuxième
chose que me me disait ce monsieur me
dit mais je vous remercie de ne pas
m'avoir répondu hier et d'avoir de vous
être renseigné pour pouvoir me répondre
aujourd'hui et je veux dire c'est ça que
j'appelle le bon sens c'est pas c'est
pas l'intell c'est pas un point de vue
de l'intell méprisant sur celui qui n'a
que le bon sens c'est simplement une
capacité à raisonner et pour moi
la science c'est l'outil indispensable
pour pouvoir reconstruire ce pays. Et
cet outil indispensable, il suppose deux
choses. Il suppose qu'on comprenne que
la science est un métier, donc tout le
monde ne peut pas tout savoir, mais que
la raison est un bien commun. Donc tout
le monde est en droit de tout
comprendre. Et et c'est en en confondant
le fait de savoir et le fait de
comprendre, on a construit une
population de demi-savant qui qui en
fume tout le monde. Et je pense que la
population vaut beaucoup mieux que ça.
Moi, je je suis pas un ingénieur, je
fais une école de commerce. On a les
mêmes oreilles, hein.
Mais je suis alors s'il y a un sujet qui
me préoccupe, c'est celui de la
recherche en France et de l'enseignement
supérieur.
La recherche en France est en une
situation que je trouve absolument
alarmante, nous sommes en train de
passer en 2è division. Nous étions en
première division, nous sommes en train
de passer en 2è division. Depuis
1995, l'effort de recherche de la France
n'a pas augmenté alors qu'il explosait
dans les autres pays. Nous sommes alors
je vais donner des chiffres
alors non c'est des chiffres sourcés
carrés.
Nous sommes à 2,2 % du PIB pour l'effort
de recherche. L'Allemagne est 3,1
comme le PIB allemand est plus gros que
le nôtre. Vous imaginez un petit peu ce
que cela fait et leur objectif c'est 3,5
et les Coréens les Coréens c'est 4 et
demi %.
Et les Chinois ?
Les Chinois on sait pas, on sait pas
bien mais c'est certainement de l'ordre
de 3 % parce que les Américains sont au
3 à 3 et demi. Et la France stingue d'un
2,2 %. Nous avons pris l'engagement
pourtant de de de d'aller à 3 % mais
nous ne respectons pas cet engagement.
l'engagement encore une stratégie. On a
pris ça non à Lisbonne
en 2005 au moment de la conférence de
Lisbonne
dans au niveau européen. La conséquence
de cela en terme de publication
scientifique, c'est un des
un des thermomètres qu'on utilise pour
savoir où se situent les pays en terme
de de science. En terme de publication
scientifique, nous sommes 13e dans le
monde
à égalité avec le Brésil.
Est-ce que les Français ont le
conscience qu'ils sont 13e dans le monde
en terme de recherche ? Je pense que
les premiers au niveau des impôt Louis.
Mais c'est pas une question c'est pas
une question d'impôts. C'est
si si les impôts vont vers la recherche,
moi je suis pas contre je suis pas du
tout contre les impôts et je pense que
il faut en payer et je supprim en payer
plus que ce que je paye actuellement
parce que je fais partie des gens aisés
et que je pense qu'il faut que les gens
aisés payent plus
si on veut que la
Et combien ta pension de retraite ?
Elle est considérable. C'est-à-dire,
je ne peux pas donner le chiffre.
Pourquoi ? Parce que vous le connaissez
pas.
Non, je peux pas le connaître.
Il y a combien de zéos ?
Il y a des zéros. Oui, mais euh je pense
que c'est extrêmement important queon
prenne conscience de notre faiblesse en
reche en recherche. Quant à la science,
l'effondrement des mathématiques dans
l'enseignement français
se traduit par le fait qu'on il y a pas
s'il y a pas de mathématiques, je parle
sous le contrôle de Yve, il y a pas de
chercheur, il y a pas d'ingénieur, il y
a pas de technicien et les et la et la
baisse des mathématiques qui était une
de nos forces du mathématique. La baisse
des mathématiques fait que nous allons
avoir des problèmes avec nos ingénieurs,
nous allons avoir des problèmes avec nos
techniciens et nous allons problèmes
avec avec les chercheurs. Et si on
continue les chercheurs à payer les
chercheurs au lance-pierre et à ne pas
leur offrir des conditions de travail
correctes, et bien ces chercheurs vont
les travailler ailleurs.
Tu veux ?
Ah, je ne je ne peux qu'abonder dans ce
sens-là. J'ai passé une bonne partie de
ma carrière dans le milieu académique à
faire de la recherche. Euh il y a une
chose qui va par rapport au moment où
j'ai commencé, je veux dire la vie des
jeunes
C'est ça. La vie des jeunes enseignants
chercheurs, je veux dire, c'est un
cauchemar. C'est-à-dire, ils ont la
seule chance qu'ils ont, c'est encore de
pouvoir un peu choisir les sujets sur
lesquels ils travaillent et beaucoup les
gens avec qui il travaillent. Mais
fondamentalement, faut que vous sachiez
que quand on recrute quelqu'un au CNRS,
j'ai fait partie des commissions de
recrutement au CNRS, vous avez des
candidats de toute première bour. Euh,
il faudrait vraiment être une brêle pour
une commission pour recruter quelqu'un
de pas bon, hein. C'est on a des très
bons candidats qui arrivent avec des
très bons projets, qui veulent aller
dans des très bons labos. Une fois qu'on
les a recruté, il passent les cinq
premières années à essayer de trouver
des sous pour faire un projet autre que
celui sur lesquels on les a recruté. Je
veux dire, ça a pas le sens commun. Je
veux dire, quand vous recrutez quelqu'un
dans une université digne de ce nom, il
arrive avec un package. On lui donne les
moyens de pouvoir commencer une activité
de recherche. Si je regarde les et là,
je parle du du CNS. Si je regarde le la
situation des jeunes enseignants
chercheurs, des maîtres de conférence
qu'on peut recruter, je veux dire les
charges d'enseignement sont juste
gigantesque parce que comme il y a plus
assez de monde pour le faire ou que on
tient, on s'imagine que il suffit de
faire des tas d'heures de cours pour
occuper les pour occuper les élèves, ben
vous retrouvez avec des jeunes qui font
1 2 3 services euh l'apothéose étant
dans les IUT, dans les IUT, rentrer dans
une IUT, ça veut dire que toute activité
de recherche est finie. Donc ça veut
dire qu'on est dans une situation
où on a un vivier de gens qui sont très
bien et on a une machine à broyer les
gens qui sont très bien. Ceux qui
survivent, il y en a, Dieu merci, qui
survivent, euh ils survivent parce
qu'ils ont vraiment la foi. Et je pense
que cette situation là, elle va pas
pouvoir perdurer très longtemps. Alors
maintenant, je vais revenir à un autre
point. Euh, on nous dit alors maintenant
le nouveau dada, c'est dire
l'innovation. Paf, ça y est, on va faire
de l'innovation. Enfin, l'innovation, ça
se fait pas comme ça. L'innovation, ça
se fait avec des gens, ça se fait avec
des moyens, ça se fait quelqu'un qui est
innovant, c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a
une liberté d'innover. C'est pas si on a
on avait dit que si on avait lancé un
grand programme pour l'innovation dans
le domaine de l'éclairage à la fin du
19e siècle, on aurait amélioré la
paraapine. Euh et donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut il faut laisser aussi aux
gens la possibilité de penser en dehors
des des chemins prédéfinis. Moi je je
suis prof au Canada quand les ils ont un
système de grs euh qui
de de prime pas de prime de de
financement de financement de de leur
recherche. Euh ils ont ce système là, il
y a des il y a des une partie de leur
financement qui est lié à des projets et
il y a une partie de leur financement
qui est je veux développer tel type de
compétence. Et c'est comme ça qu'on peut
construire
qu'on peut construire les choses. C'est
pas en dire c'est pas en disant je vais
faire de l'innovation puis tiens je vais
prendre le dernier sujet que j'ai lu
dans la table des matières du nouvel ou
de l'express ou du point et je veux dire
il faut absolument lancer un grand
programme sur schroumpf. Je pense que il
faut se dire que pour qu'on puisse
vraiment faire de l'innovation, il faut
que les gens aient les moyens de
travailler. Il faut que les gens aient
l'envie de travailler et il faut qu'ils
aient la liberté de travailler. Et tant
qu'on fera pas ça, et bien on va avoir
des gens on va on va on va détruire de
la matière grise et une matière grise
dont on a impérativement besoin. On
reconstruira reconstruira pas
l'industrie de ce pays si on ne la
construit pas sur des compétences, des
compétences qui sont capables d'évoluer
et des compétences de gens qui ont envie
de faire.
Alors ça tombe bien, on a on a un
ingénieur ici puis on a un monsieur qui
connaît un peu les avions. Donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on perd de
la vitesse, on décroche ? Qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans l'instabilité
thermodynamique ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Donc ça pète, ça décroche et ensuite
ça se disloque, on est d'accord ? Jusque
là, le constat est simple. Qu'est-ce qui
se passe quand on a un président de la
République qui en 2018 dit "Je vais
fermer X réacteur nucléaire qui ferme
Fenim parce que ça fait bien auprès des
écolos. Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
l'industrie quand derrière l'énergie
explose ? parce que un on n pas vu la
guerre venir de on n pas pris les
mesures proactives pour éviter de se
faire avoir par des stratégies de guerre
froide tellement classique cous de fil
blanc qu'est-ce qui se passe quand à la
tête de l'état on a excusez-moi du mot
des touristes
oui encore une fois je te dis moi le
fondamentalement j'ai pas envie de
pleurer sur les renversé je veux dire on
a fait une série une bêtise. Bon, OK,
maintenant comment est-ce qu'on
reconstruit ? Je veux dire, la tête des
DF maintenant, vous avez quelqu'un comme
Bernard Fontana qui est quelqu'un
d'absolument remarquable, un vrai
industriel qui construit des trucs, qui
a l'habitude, qui a pris une boîte qui
était en faillite quasiment, qui était à
Riva et qui l'a ramené avec Fraatome à
une à une de boîte qui est qui est saine
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
fonctionnement. Euh Bernard Fantana, je
me souviens quand il a redonné le nom de
Framat qui était arriva je ne sais plus
quoi, euh il dit "Je veux que cette
entreprise porte le nom qu'elle portait
quand elle était dirigée par des
ingénieurs." Et quand vous le voyez de
l'intérieur euh vous rendez compte ce
que ça veut dire. Donc c'est pas
impossible. On parlait tout à l'heure de
la Corée du Sud. Prenez un autre exemple
dans la région, c'est Singapour.
Singapour était un pays pauvre et c'est
un pays qui est devenu un pays riche. Pr
qui le sacrifice ? Ah ! Alors à l'époque
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il était un
peu directif le dirigeur de de
Singapour. C'est le bon qu'on puisse
dire. Bon enfin il était directif pas au
point de tuer des gens quand même.
Pareil pour la Corée
hein. Euh mais je pense que ce qui
quelqu'un euh encore une fois vous
pouvez avoir quelqu'un qui est directif
et autocrate et euh qui est un tyran et
vous pouvez avoir quelqu'un qui est
directif est porté par la population. Je
pense que ce qui s'est passé à Singapour
et ce qui s'est passé en Corée du Sud,
c'est ils avaient un quelqu'un qui était
directif, mais il y avait une confiance
de la population pour pouvoir se dire il
faut qu'on grandisse, il faut qu'on
aille dans cette directionlà. Et là,
vous avez des gens qui sont directifs,
mais ils sont directifs dans un
mouvement bronien, quoi. Donc euh, je
veux dire, on va pas aller bien loin
avec ça. Mais ceci dit, encore une fois,
le cœur du problème, c'est la conviction
de la population de la nécessité de
reconstruire une industrie qui est ce
qui leur permet de bien vivre.
Sur l'énergie, il y a deux pays qui ont
fait des bêtises en Europe, l'Allemagne
et la France.
Bah, c'est pas des moindres. Oui,
l'Allemagne parce qu'elle a elle s'est
mis dans la main du gaz russe et elle a
cru que la Russie était son arrière
court et qu'elle allait trouver
l'énergie et les matières premières.
En fait, ce sera la Chine qui va jouer
ce rôle, qui va qui va utiliser la
Russie pour cela. Et
et on est mal barré à cause de ça.
Et on est et on est en difficulté parce
que l'Allemagne est en très grande
difficulté sur le plan énergétique. Il
faut pas le dire. Il faut pas le dire.
et la France parce que en pendant 20
ans, on n' aucune politique énergétique
que l'énergie a été confiée au ministère
de l'environnement qui ne l'a vu que
sous un seul euh euh
angle qui était celui euh de l'écologie,
mais pas du tout de l'indépendance, pas
du tout de la compétitivité
et cetera. On a on a confié l'énergie à
des gens qui n'avaient aucune conception
globale de ce à quoi servait l'énergie
dans un pays. Et donc
en d'autres termes
il faut parler franchement en en on a on
on heureusement on n'a pas détruit en
dehors de on a fermé Fessanheim qui est
une une aberration une aberration. On a
mis
une macronite,
on on a mis à un actif qui valait des
milliards
et qui avait été en plus rénové.
Donc c'est une c'est une aberration.
Mais heureusement, il reste 57 réacteurs
qui nous aident bien à produire de
l'énergie. Et et à partir de là et à
partir de là, il faut rebondir et je
pense qu'il faut mettre vite en en
œuvre le programme nucléaire euh qui a
été décidé, les les six euh
les six réacteurs plus je pense le h
autres qui viend
6 + 8, c'est pas un peu petit bras ?
Commençons d'abord par en faire 6 + 8.
Non mais
moi je je me je me retourne euh
Non mais moi je mon opin mon opinion
personnelle c'est qu'il en faudrait 20
d'ici 2050.
Merci
parce que il faudrait il va falloir
commencer à assurer le renouvellement
des réacteurs actuels. Même si on a
prolongé leur durée de vieux ils
viennent à à obsolescence. Donc il faut
je je pense qu'une vingtaine de
réacteurs d'ici 2050 mais on en ferait
14. J'aurais déjà le sentiment qu'on a
fait une partie du chemin et je je je
suis quand même préoccupé de voir la
lenteur avec laquelle on s'engage dans
ce programme. On nous avait dit ça ça
sera prêt en 2035 le premier réacteur
nouveau euh au-delà de Flamville. Euh ça
c'est plus maintenant 2035, c'est 2038
et ça va et et ça risque de de se
décaler encore. Je pense qu'il faut
qu'on soit beaucoup plus proactif et que
on mette en œuvre ce programme le plus
rapidement possible.
Oui. Alors je tout à fait d'accord.
Alors maintenant le la question enfin la
raison du 6 + 8 pour moi ça veut dire
que ça ça nous remet en état de faire.
Ve dire une industrie ne peut fabriquer
que si elle fait
absolument. On on ne décrète pas dans un
ministère, vous allez faire ça. Et quand
on parle avec les les papis qui ont
construit le parc électronucléaire dans
les années 70, c'est vachement
intéressant. Il y en a c'était c'est
Indiana Jones quoi. C'est mais il me
racontait que bah ça a pas été à l'enfol
tranquille hein. Les premières années,
les premiers réacteurs bah il a fallu
essuyer les plâtres. On savait pas
faire. On venait d'acheter une licence,
il a fallu l'adapter. Enfin bon, c'est
mais il y avait une volonté de faire et
cette volonté de faire a fait qu'on a
quand même réussi à construire une enfin
58 réacteurs. On a réussi encore il y
avait des années où il y en avait 5 par
an. Je veux dire la la génération la
France 6 par le record vous sa mais la
génération qu'on a maintenant elle est
capable de faire ça. Il faut arrêter de
lui dire qu'on sait pas faire.
La Chine fait un par mois
mais la Chine fait un par mois mais ils
sont 20 fois plus nombreux que nous. Ils
sont quand même milliard 400 milliard
et puis encore une fois c'est pas c'est
pas une question de c'est pas une
question de record, c'est une question
d'analyse des besoins et d'analyse des
besoins qui sont étalés sur un sur une
certaine durée qui correspond à la
manière dont les besoins vont arriver
sur la PPE dont on parlait tout à
l'heure qui est le le le le nonsens
intégral en terme de planification
programmation plurielle de l'énergie
qui est un nonens un non sens intégral
en terme de planification. Le truc
en question, je veux dire, il y a eu un
rapport de l'Académie des Sciences, un
rapport de l'académie des technologies,
un rapport du au commissaire à l'énergie
atomique. Tout ça vous dit, grosso modo,
vous êtes en train de développer
massivement
des des énergies renouvelables pour
pouvoir avoir massivement un excédent de
un excès de d'électricité parce que vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir. en
avoir besoin et pour les voitures
électriques et pour machin ou pour truc
à part que la consommation l'électricité
elle baisse de manière continue. Donc ça
veut dire qu'on n'a pas l'urgence qui
justifie le fait de développer de
manière des des projets absolument
pharaoniques. Les centrales nucléaires,
bah ça mettra le temps qu'il faudra pour
les faire et ça nous donnera la quantité
d'électricité dont on a besoin au moment
où on en aura besoin.
Elle baisse depuis quand ?
Elle est bon c'est
elle est elle est elle est stable. Elle
elle elle varie en fonction de la
conjoncture. Elle est à peu près stable
à 440 TWh
par an. Bon, ça se balade autour de
440h. Mais
la croissance française, elle est
comment ?
Bah la croissance française c'est 1 %.
Oui, c'est grosso modo
la largeur du trait quoi.
Oui, on est quand même une croissance
faible, une industrie qui ne redécolle
pas même si elle a arrêté de baisser.
Tout ça ne favorise pas la consommation.
Moi je pense que la consultation va
venir le jour où on va électrifier le
chauffage de l'ensemble des des
bâtiments et des logements. Le jour où
on aura des voitures et où les
transports seront complètement
électrifiés, le jour où l'industrie sera
passée à l'électrique, je pense qu'on
aura besoin d'électricité. Mais ça va
prendre du temps. Et moi je suis
d'accord avec Yve. Il y a aucune hâte à
faire des des pan à importer de Chine
des panneaux solaires et des des
éoliennes voitures et des voitures et
des batteries et des terres.
Oui, mais je je on pourra y revenir
là-dessus.
Ouais. B on y va tout de suite. Alors
al je pense que sur les batteries
euh il y a il y a actuellement des gig
ce qu'on appelle des gig factory. Des
grosses des grosses usines qui sont en
construction. Elles ont énormément de
difficultés
à à fonctionner parce que on apprend le
métier de fabrication de batterie en
grande série. On a des Chinois qui
savent le faire parce que ils ont 10 ans
d'avance sur nous
et si on les laisse faire, ils vont
déferler sur sur
l'Europe. Moi je moi je pense qu'il faut
adopter un comportement modeste. Nous
sommes par rapport à eux dans la
situation d'un pays émergent et eux
c'est le pays qui a la technologie. Et
bien il faut leur proposer ce que ce
qu'ils nous ont fait, ce qu'ils nous ont
obligé à faire. C'est-à-dire vous venez
chez nous, vous faites des sociétés
communes 5050 et vous nous passez la
technologie. Moi quand je quand j'étais
chez Airbus, je les autorités chinoises
m'ont dit "Vous voulez continuer à
vendre des avions chez nous ?" Ben, il
va falloir commencer à à travailler, à
coopérer avec Comac, le fabricant euh le
fabricant chinois d'avion.
Il ressemble beaucoup euh l'erbus à 320,
hein, le comac, non ?
Ouais, il ressemble euh au 737, à
l'irbus plutôt à 320 parce qu'il est
mieux que le 737. Mais bon, mais c'est
c'est normal. C'est normal, ils en ont
acheté des centaines, ils peuvent le
démonter, ils savent comment on le fait.
Puis il y a une usine d'Airbus en Chine.
Mais c'est normal, il y a du transfert
de technologie, c'est inévitable. Mais
maintenant, il faut se transfert
technologie. Il ils viennent de la Chine
vers nous.
Donc là, notre industrie a perdu une
c'est combien 20 25 % euh de de
compétitivité à cause du prix d'énergie.
Euh comment ça comment ça se fait que
mon boulanger il paye cinq fois plus
cher son énergie ?
Alors euh tu sais que j'ai l'habitude de
répondre aux questions qui correspondent
à mon domaine de compétence. Je ne sais
pas.
La boulangerie c'est pas ton rayon.
Non, c'est pas que la boulangerie c'est
pas mon rayon. c'est que ce qui fait le
tarif de l'électricité est quelque chose
que personnellement je ne comprends pas.
Si tu veux avoir des questions sur ce
des des réponses à viser sur ce genre de
choses, tu demandes à Jacques Percebois
de venir parler avec toi et là tu auras
quelqu'un qui te dira bah en gros
comment on construit un prix de
l'électricité, comment ce trucl ça se
marie plus ou moins bien avec le avec le
paysage européen quels sont
il pourra te le dire. Moi ça je sais
pas. Mais par contre, je vais revenir
sur l'électricité.
Euh je suis pas je voudrais pas qu'on
ait l'impression que je dise que le la
consommation d'électricité va pas
augmenter. Je dis qu'elle va augmenter.
Je dis qu'elle doit augmenter parce que
jusqu'à plus en plein formé, la manière
la plus efficace de décarboner notre
économie d'utiliser une électricité
décarbonée. Maintenant une fois qu'on a
dit ça, ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir
une idée à peu près claire de combien
j'en ai besoin. avec quel avec quelle
quelle rapidité ça doit être développé,
comment je mets ça sur un réseau ? C'est
quand même pas tout à fait un détail.
Quelle est la stabilité qui va en
arriver ? Enfin, je veux dire avec
l'histoire en en
Espagne, c'est complètement
extraordinaire. Ve dire s'est passé en
Espagne en train de nous dire il faut
regarder quel est le phénomène
déclenchant. Alors moi franchement je
rigole parce que ça veut dire grosso
modo hon 5e étage d'un immeuble on a
enlevé toutes les barrières et il y a
quelqu'un qui glisse sur un pâ roulette
qui va s'écraser en bas et on se pose la
question de savoir quelle est la couleur
du pâat roulette. C'est juste stupide.
La question c'est pas quel est le
phénomène déclenchant. La question c'est
quelles sont les mesures qui ont fait
que le système est devenu instable ? Et
c'est ça les questions qu'il faut
prendre. Si on a Mais le fait même qu'on
se focalise sur les éléments déclenchant
pour moi c'est révélateur de l'époque.
C'est révélateur du fait qu'on narrive
pas à penser les causes comme des esps
structurels structuraux. On ne pense les
causes que comme des événements. Et
c'est comme ça qu'on a des gouvernants
qui accumulent les anneries comme on
enfile des perles parce qu'ils ne font
que penser à des événements quand ils
pensent pas carrément à des déclarations
et à rien d'autre. Donc je pense qu'il y
a quelque chose de très profond qui
revient à la planification tout à
l'heure. Il faut apprendre à penser
l'ensemble et à le penser dans sa
totalité. Et donc je pense qu'on aura
besoin d'électricité parce qu'on doit
électrifier notre économie. Je pense que
cette électricité doit être abordable,
que cette électricité doit être stable.
Donc ça veut dire que la toute première
chose que devrait faire un plan, au lieu
de nous pondre des machins comme la
programmation plinelle de l'énergie, on
se demande vraiment ce qu'ils avait fumé
quand ils ont pendu ce truc-là. Au lieu
de au lieu de faire des machins comme
ça, on devrait commencer par faire une
analyse saine des besoins, de la
typologie des besoins. Si je regarde
rien que les besoins industriels, il y a
des industries qui sont électrifiables,
donc ils ne sont pas dans celles qui
sont électrifiables, il y en a où on
peut arrêter l'électricité sans détruire
l'outil industriel. D'autres on peut
pas. Ah le fourneau il aime pas trop
mais le mais même chose je veux dire un
four à verre je peux l'électrifier pas
facilement et pas complètement mais si
j'arrête mon four à vert c'est mort donc
ça veut dire que moi je il y a des tas
de gens qui font des des microréacteurs
qui sont venu dire vous êtes directeur
scientifique de Saoba, vous êtes un
nucléocrate incurable euh est-ce que
vous voudriez pas qu'on vous mette un un
petit réacteur sur une un de vos
foursverrier ? dit bon un électrifier le
favrier, je suis pas encore complètement
sûr de savoir faire et puis deux même
pas en rêve de mettre un petit réacteur
parce qu'imaginez que quelqu'un vient me
dise "Bah celui-là il faut l'arrêter euh
je suis mort." Donc ça veut dire que par
nature une industrie électrifiable avec
un besoin d'électricité stable va aller
sur un réseau stable. Et bien cette
analyse là, je l'ai jamais vu faire dans
la PPE. Au lieu de ça, il y a des tas de
déclarations d'intention de machin de
trucs et que je vais vous le reprendre
envers et que non, c'est pas sérieux.
Pour expliquer quand même la différence
de prix d'énergie entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis, euh je suis encore une fois,
je suis pas un ingénieur mais euh pour
le gaz,
nous achetons du gaz aux États-Unis.
Ce
ser cher,
nous nous l'achetons à son prix. Il faut
le liquéfier, il faut le transporter,
il faut le regéifier
et ça multiplie le prix du gaz par 3.
Et comme ils nous le vendent
plus cher qu'il le donnent à leurs
propres industriels, ça veut dire que
nous payons le gaz quatre fois plus cher
que les Américains.
Quant à l'électricité, ils produisent de
l'électricité avec des centrales
nucléaires amorties et ils produisent de
l'électricité avec des énergies fossiles
qu'ils ont en abondance. Et ça fait un
un mélange qui fait que le prix de
l'électricité aux États-Unis qui a
toujours été plus bas qu'en Europe,
hein, qui a toujours été plus bas,
actuellement, il est deux fois plus bas
qu'en Europe. Ça veut dire que c'est un
avantage concurrentiel formidable. C'est
une pompe aspirante pour les industries
qui euh euh consomment soit du gaz, soit
de l'électricité. La chimie allemande
est très qui bon consomme du gaz et
évidemment tenté d'aller aux États-Unis
et euh c'est ça sera le cas de toutes
les industries si nous ne sommes pas
capables de reconstituer
une énergie
qui doit être électrique puisque le gaz
produit du du CO2.
une électricité à un prix convenable et
tout l'objectif de de d'F, c'est
d'arriver à nous sortir un kilwh à un
prix qui soit compétitif et il ne pourra
le faire.
C'est pas déjà le cas.
C'est c'est cher.
C'est cher. Actuellement
le le le le
prix d'électricité
et et de vendu par EDF est très marqué
par le parc existant qui est stable.
Bon, donc il est pas trop cher tout
l'enjeu, c'est que l'électricité qui
sera produite par le parc qui va falloir
construire ne soit pas elle trop chère.
François Berou là,
non, c'est très difficile.
Il nous annonçait le MAW à combien ? le
MAWh. Actuellement le le le coût pour
euh EDF
estimé par la Cour des comptes et par
euh la la commission de régulation de
l'électricité à autour de 60 €.
À combien à combien sera euh sortira le
le méga water des nouvelles centrales ?
C'est-à-dire les nouvelles centrales, si
on arrive à s'endetter, à les
construire, à les approvisionner en
créant combustible,
pour six centrales, il faut compter 100
bards à peu près
à peu près parce que il y a 60 milliards
pour la construction, il y a 40
milliards de frais financiers.
C'est gigantesque les frais financiers.
Bon, il faut compter une centaine de
milliards et à ce prix à ce avec cette
avec ça, à combien va-t-on sortir le le
le MGAW ? J'espère qu'on le sortira à un
prix convenable. Euh travaille dessus et
regarde ce qu'il peut faire et euh il
doit d'ici la fin de l'année, je crois,
donner ses conclusions au gouvernement.
Yve, un petit rebond là-dessus ou je
pose une autre question ? Alors juste le
rebond c'est qu' il y a un aspect qui
qui est important, c'est pas simplement
le le coût des centrales et ce qui va
contrôler le coût du le coût de
l'électricité hormis toutes les taxes
qu'on peut mettre dessus, c'est la
disponibilité des centrales. Je veux
dire
on peut pas les arrêter n'importe quand,
n'importe comment. Enfin, je veux dire,
faut faire les choses sérieusement. Et
ça ça ne ça ne préjuge pas de la sûreté.
La sûreté doit être prim première dans
ce truclà. Mais mais même avec une
sûreté première, on narrête pas une
centrale quand il y a un chat qui passe
dans la porte quoi. Enfin, c'est donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut vraiment revenir à
une réflexion approfondie sur les
décisions qui sont prises et encore une
fois que ces décisions là soient prises
sur des critères qui sont des critères
scientifiques et techniques et pas des
critères de comment je réponds au
journalistes.
Non mais
ce qui est notre cas. Je suis pas
journaliste. Non, je suis pas
journaliste. J'ai eu la chance d'avoir
un vieux mentor qui était journaliste
et et je suis
et moi je je n'ai rien contre les
journalistes
pour leur métier et moi je fais le mien.
Bon euh arrêtez de me déconcentrer vous
deux là.
Revenons. J'aimerais qu'on prenne de la
hauteur qu'on ait une vision
géopolitique, géostratégque,
géostratégique et de guerre économique.
Quand nous on on contemple la situation
européenne, on contemple les décisions
qui ont été prises ou les plans sur la
comète qui ont été pris qui ont été
pris, pardon, on se dit les Américains,
les Chinois et les Russes sont en train
de dépesser l'Europe pour gagner du
temps pour ensuite se mettre une grosse
peignée. Et comme à notre tête on a des
touristes,
on fait ça gément.
Louis,
l'Europe c'est un problème.
Je pense que nous sommes en face de
trois échecs de l'Europe.
L'Europe, c'est la zone de croissance la
plus faible dans le monde.
Le rapport Dragi a montré que l'Europe
c'était une zone qui était en train de
décrocher complètement en terme
d'innovation par rapport aux États-Unis
et à la Chine.
Oh, tu déconnes Loui. On a fait des
bouchons de bouteille.
Oui. Et et et le troisième élément qui
m'a m'a m'idé que je croyais que nous
étions la première puissance commerciale
du monde. Nous sommes incapables de
créer un rapport de force avec la Chine
et les États-Unis. On l'a vu dans la
négociation avec les États-Unis.
Donc ces trois échecs nous interpellent
et moi je me demande s'il y a pas un
problème de gouvernance de l'Europe. Ah
si on ne doit pas euh réfléchir à cela.
Moi ce que je vois c'est c'est je vois
une commission
je vois une commission de Bruxelles
qui empiète sans arrêt sur les pouvoirs
de à la limite des traités.
Quand je vois madame Vleyenne qui
propose de faire un mur anti-drone, mais
c'est pas son boulot. C'est pas son
boulot. Moi, je veux qu'elle s'occupe de
ces des compétences de la commission qui
sont le commerce et la concurrence pour
dans le domaine économique.
Quand je euh euh les commissaires et le
Parlement comme ils n'ont pas des moyens
financiers et l'Europe n'est pas prête
et les pays européens ne sont pas prêts
à donner des moyens financiers
gigantesques à l'Union européenne et à
la Commission,
ben ils font des règlements. Ils pontent
des règlements. C'est une machine à
pondre des règlements
et et et de manière très déconnectée par
rapport à la réalité. Vous évoquiez euh
le l'interdiction de vendre des voitures
thermiques au-delà de 2035. Moi,
j'attends de voir l'étude d'impact. Il
n'y a pas eu d' d' d'étude d'impact.
Elle fait trois pages cette aid des
feux,
pardon.
Les aides des feux, il y a pas eu
d'études d'impact. Oui, c'est c'est
c'est à mon avis c'est quand même plus
limité comme problème. On
leur propose quelque chose de limité,
ils sont pas cap de le gérer. C'est vrai
qu'il y a pas eu d'études d'impact, mais
quand c'est la première industrie
européenne et qu'on lui on lui propose
seulement d'arrêter sa production sur ce
qu'elle sait faire pour passer à une
production qu'elle ne sait pas faire,
qu'il faut qu'elle apprenne et qu'on lui
dis c'est en 2035 que vous devez avoir
fini de votre apprentissage, je pense
qu'on a pris une décision euh
aberrente. En fait, on a pris 2035 parce
que le Parlement voulait 2030 et que le
Conseil européen voulait 2040. Donc on a
tranché au milieu, je caricature mais
c'est à peu près ça. Ce 2035 n'a pas été
réfléchi et je crois que c'est le type
de décision qui qui qui pose un problème
absolument massif quant au processus de
gouvernance. Alors maintenant, il
propose de revenir en arrière. La France
est contre. Pourquoi ? parce que les
industriels français se sont engagés
là-dedans. Donc ils ont des programmes.
Un industriel, on lui dit en 2035, tu
pourras plus vendre de voiture
thermique. Donc ben comme il comme il
faut qu'il bosse,
il a un programme pour arrêter de vendre
des voitures thermiques en 2035. Et
maintenant on lui dirait "Ah bah oui,
c'est peut-être pas 2035, c'est 2040.
C'est c'est on est reparti.
Pour gère une boîte comme ça ? C'est
possible ?
C'est impossible de gérer une boîte. Moi
je sais je sais. Alors, je peux je peux
je peux poser
alors le 3è le 3è sujet quand même de
gouvernance pour moi, c'est qu'à 27 ça
peut pas fonctionner correctement.
Je je je
te rassure, ça fonctionne à un.
Oui.
Frexite les gars,
ça ça peut être pardon.
Frexit.
Ben non, je pas du tout. Je propose pas
du tout le frexit. Je propose je je
touche même pas au traité mais je
propose qu'on en revienne
à des choses simples, que la commission
fasse son boulot et que son boulot et
que elle change de logiciel aussi bien
sur les problèmes de de de de commerce
extérieur avec une application
réelle du principe de réciprocité qui
fasse que lorsqu'on nous empêche de de
commercer dans un pays, ce pays ne
viennent pas commercer chez nous que
lorsqueon applixe les réglementations de
sécurité, les ceux qui les les les
pays qui exportent vers l'Europe soit
obligé d'appliquer ses règles de
sécurité, ça ça me paraît important sur
la et sur la concurrence qu'on nous
laisse créer des champions européens. Je
vois actuellement, il y a une projet de
fusion dans le domaine sp des satellites
entre
Talès, Airbus et Leonardo. C'est une
bonne chose. C'est une bonne chose parce
que c'est pas la concurrence européenne
qui est importante pour les satellites,
c'est la concurrence mondiale est en
train de se faire balayer par Musk et
Starling et et et la et la constellation
de de d'Amazon. Donc il faut qu'on soit
capable de de de se battre et il faut
pour cela qu'on regroupe nos forces.
J'attends de voir ce que la commission
va dire parce que effectivement on passe
de deux gros constructeurs en Europe à
un seul. Est-ce qu'ils vont dire "Mais
il y a monopole ? Monopole ça n'a aucun
sens puisque le marché est mondial."
Ça c'est vraiment pour moi important que
la commission se recentre sur ses
compétences et qu'elle change son
logiciel. La seconde chose, c'est que on
donne la subsidiarité. C'est ce qui peut
être fait dans les États n'est pas fait
n'est pas obligatoirement fait par une
armée de fonctionnaires à Bruxelles. Et
et troisièmement, qu'on laisse les États
libres de s'associer entre eux, entre
volontaires pour faire des choses. Moi,
je viens de signer avec mes collègues,
mes anciens collègues d'Airbus de Rolls,
de BAE en Angleterre, une tribune dans
lequelle nous disons il faut créer une
agence européenne de de défense qui soit
chargé du de de de mener les programmes
de défense qui seraient décidé par les
États. C'est les États qui décident de
et qui apportent les financements. Il
faut pour mener ces programmes que il y
ait une agence qui soit dotée des moyens
de choisir les bons fabricants après
compétition qui soit chargé aussi de
s'assurer que ceux qui gagnent font
travailler ceux qui ont perdu pour qu'il
y ait pas de perte de compétence. Euh
mais sinon, on est parti pour ce qui se
passe sur l'avion de combat du futur,
c'est-à-dire des bagarres
incessante entre français allemands. Il
faut que les anglais ils soient associés
parce que l'industrie de défense est
avec les anglais. Donc il faut qu'il y
ait cette capacité des États et des
entreprises à travailler ensemble sans
contrainte et sans que la commission
vienne leur dire ça ça ressemble à du
monopole, ça ressemble à de de de
concurrence.
Louis, on peut enlever les lunettes
roses là.
On peut
Oui.
Les Allemands nous mettent des couteaux
dans le dos régulièrement.
Les anglais font la même chose.
Non mais
non mais il y a pas de nom mais la la
vie est comme ça.
La vie est comme ça.
L'union est un combat.
D'accord.
C'est c'est pas moi qui le disait, c'est
Benoît Frachon,
l'ancien leader de la CGT. L'Union est
en combat.
Nous savons que l'Union européenne
le lieu où les intérêts des pays
européens s'affrontent. On le sait ça.
Ça n'empêche pas qu'on puisse faire des
choses ensemble. Moi, j'ai dirigé Airbus
quand même pendant 6 ans de ma vie.
Je sais ce que c'est que que de
travailler avec les Allemands, avec les
anglais, on peut on doit travailler avec
eux, on est capable de le faire.
Quand les Allemands nous mettent des
bâtons dans les roues sur notre système
nucléaire,
mais ça c'est c'estensé qu' mais mais
moi c'est pas tellement les Allemands,
c'est le relais de la commission pour
faire cela.
Ça c'est autre chose hein. Et je pense
que maintenant avec MERS on a
c'est celui qui a des petites lunettes
et qui réfléchit qui va être obligé de
mettre 12 milliards sur on a un homme
qui me paraît un petit peu moins
crétin
engagé dans la lutte antinucléaire
que son prédécesseur.
Et je pense qu'il faudrait en profiter.
Je je pense que on peut rediscuter avec
les Allemands énergie, il va falloir le
faire. Non mais il faut discuter avec
eux gentiment ou il faut leur expliquer
bon ça fait 20 ans que tu essayes de me
faire des crochepates maintenant tu vas
c'est c'est un rapport de force encore
une fois c'est un rapport de force quand
on voit stourner
machin nous avons des éléments de
rapport de force dans le domaine de
l'énergie mais
qu'est-ce qui portent les éléments de
rapport de force
c'est c'est le c'est le pouvoir
politique ça
et le pouvoir politique il ressemble à
des bad boy il ressemble à quoi
écoutez moi je ne m'exprime pas sur ce
sujet hein Oui. Qu'est-ce que c'est
cette petite faussette à droite ?
Non, non, non, non, non. Je je moi je je
considère que euh nous avons encore une
fois, il faut qu'on prenne conscience,
il faut que les Français prennent
conscience que à la fois, on a besoin de
travailler avec les pays européens, à la
fois on a et en même temps que c'est un
combat.
Alors, avant de repasser la parole
avant de repasser la parole à Yve, juste
une question.
On se met à l'époque où vous étiez
patron d'Airbus genre
Ouais.
Big patron genre je vous mets au même
niveau Christophe Christophe de Margerie
feu Christophe de Margerie.
Ah bah lui il est c'est d'une enté bien
française.
Ah ouais
d'ailleurs il était très sympa.
C'est un grand patron et son successeur
est également un grand patron. On a la
chance d'avoir à la tête
la première entreprise française des
hommes de très grande qualité.
Ouais. Ouais. Et puis en plus,
Pouyané nous fait des dédicaces lors de
son assemblée générale et et on le
remercie. Ça nous a bien fait rigoler et
ça nous a réchauffé le cœur et on a
compris.
On se met dans la peau grand patron
capitaine d'industrie. Bon, il y a un
gars qui rentre dans le bureau, vous
présentez un projet et comme vous avez
grand patron, vous dites "Bon, c'est
bien, l'étude d'impact, ça a été fait."
Et le mec vous dit "Bah non, il repart
comment du bureau ? Il vole à
l'horizontal,
il a pris la chaise dans les dents.
Comment ça se passe ?
Il retourne il retourne sur son établi
pour travailler à sa copie.
il
s'il le fait une deuxième fois, il va
planter ses choux ailleurs.
Quand il quand ils sont politiques,
ben quand ils sont les ce qui était moi
je je je
sais que ce qu'est le jeu politique.
J'ai été directeur de cabinet de
ministre, je sais ce que c'est que le
jeu politique. Et dans cette affaire, ce
que je n'admets pas, c'est qu'on n pas
fait la confiance aux gens qui
connaissaient les choses. On les a même
pas consulté.
On les a mal mené, hein.
On les a pas consulté. C'est c'est c'est
quelque chose qui pour moi est
profondément choquant. Et je je pense
que ça veut dire que on a des gens qui
sont hors sol
hors sol et qui pensent que euh on peut
décider sans sans prendre la vie des
gens compétents. Moi je vois l'Académie
des Sciences dont Yve est membre. Elle
fait sur la programmation pluriéannuelle
de l'énergie un rapport.
Bon, c'est quand même la crème de la
crème en France.
Le Parti communiste a fait un bon
rapport sur l'énergie d'ailleurs.
Oui, mais je serais peut-être plus
d'accord avec celui-là.
Mais mais mais je le rapport est
remarquable.
L'Académie des technologies fait un
rapport. Tout le monde s'en fout. Tout
le monde s'en fout. On continue à faire
une PPE qui ne ressemble à rien et qui
est le fruit de l'affrontement des lobby
et de l'équilibre que cet affrontement
des lobby permet plus ou moins. Il y a
pas de conception d'ensemble, il y a pas
de vision. On ne sait pas où on va en
2040, en 2050 sur l'énergie 2040, c'est
demain.
Je suis moi je je trouve que c'est c'est
c'est presque choquante sur le plan
démocratique.
C'est-à-dire que le pays
n'est pas dans ses forces les plus
compétentes associé à un travail qui
suppose beaucoup de connaissance
et et et et et qu'on décide au doigt
mouillé.
Je suis quand même préoccupé par cela.
Louis, votre tempérance m'impressionne.
Quand on a des gens qui sont des
capitaines de la France qui pilotent aux
doigts mouillés qui ont été formé à
gérer quand la mairie est calme, quand
tout va bien, quand on peut faire de la
dette à gogo et pas cher et quand on
peut avoir de l'énergie bon marché,
quand la mer commence à s'énerver, que
la dette commence à coûter plus cher et
que l'énergie commence à se rarifier,
les matières premières à se rarifier,
quand on est scientifique de l'Académie
des Sciences, on va dire de l'Amie de
Vulcin
quand on les voit.
Écoute, je crois que j'ai dit à peu près
tout ce que j'avais à dire sur ça. Euh,
je vous citerai pas très souvent, mais
je citerai volontiers Warren Buffett qui
dit "C'est quand la mer se retire qu'on
voit qui portait un maillot de bain." Je
pense qu'on est juste en train de voir
ça.
Mais je voudrais revenir sur la
construction sur sur l'Europe parce que
le sujet qu'on abordé, c'est le sujet de
la de la réindustrialisation qui pour
moi est absolument essentiel. Et je
pense qu'on ne peut pas penser la
réindustrialisation
sans penser l'Europe. Mais quand je dis
penser l'Europe, c'est pas l'Europe
peut-être qu'elle existe. Je pense qu'on
est dans une situation où on a une
structure qui a été créée pour éviter
les conflits entre pays et grosso modo
éviter les monopoles de façon à ce que
concurrence libre et bien et non faussée
et cetera et cetera. Alors que le vrai
problème, le problème actuel, c'est que
l'Europe est un ensemble qui est un
ensemble qui est comparable à ce que
peuvent être l'Amérique du Nord et le
Canada, qui est comparable à ce que peut
être la Chine et que la réindustrisation
dans un univers mondialisé, c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit penser à cette
échelle-là. Donc ça c'est un premier
point. Mais une fois que j'ai dit ça, je
dois dire que j'ai d'infin tristesse à
voir l'Europe.
Je suis un européen convaincu.
J'ai vu un certain nombre de choses dans
les dernières années qui fait froid dans
de l'eau. Je veux dire quand on voit
madame Van Derleyen en train de négocier
avec Donald Trump la ch de je ne sais
combien de de milliards d'énergie
d'énergie fossile 700 milliards
d'énergie fossiles
enfin trop euh et je me dis là il y a il
y a il y a un malaise quoi. Je veux
dire, c'est ça va pas. Quand je vois la
même en train d'expliquer queon va
acheter des SMR à aux États-Unis alors
que la seule chose que l'Europe a réussi
à faire dans le nucléaire, c'était de
dire "On va faire des petits réacteurs."
J'ai je j'ai mon avis sur les petits
réacteurs, mais il y a il y a un truc
qui est une incohérence totale. Je veux
dire, avec des amis avec des alliés
comme ça, vous avez pas besoin
d'ennemis, hein. Donc quand vous êtes
dans une situation comme ça, veut dire
que vous avez quelque chose qui a été
construit
pour un problème qui ne se pose plus et
qui est incapable de répondre au
problème que se pose le monde qui se
pose actuellement dans le monde du point
de vue de la réindustrialisation. Alors,
il y a eu un truc qui était
extraordinaire. Je sais pas si tu as vu
passer ça, il quel conseiller économique
de je sais plus quel sous de je sais
plus quel commissaire qui avait fait
juste avant de partir à la retraite où
il va être grassement payé par les
impôts des citoyens européens. Il a fait
une interview mais qui était lunaire,
absolument lunaire où expliqué que
c'était pas un problème s'il y avait
plus d'industrie lourde en Europe, que
de toute façon on achèterait la
ailleurs, on achèterait enfin à part que
à ma connaissance si je fais des
voitures fusell fuselle
électronique, je veux dire il y a quand
même besoin de longeron pour faire
rouler les voitures. Et et ce truc était
extraordinaire. Moi, il m'avait fait
penser
le les bouffons avaient comme
caractéristique de dire au roi de
manière drôle des choses qu'ils avaient
besoin de savoir mais qu'ils étaient pas
tout à fait prêts à entendre. Et puis
les abs de cours, c'est juste l'inverse.
Ça dit de manière sinistre des choses
que le roi pense déjà savoir. Ce type
là, c'est un ab de cours et je pense
qu'on a un problème dans la gouvernance
de l'Europe qui est exactement ce que
disait Louis. Je suis pas du tout
favorable à un frexit. Je suis par
contre favorable à revenir au traités et
à ce qu'on fasse ce que les traités
disent. Et euh en en terme de
gouvernance. Et maintenant, ça m'a amené
à poser une autre question.
Fortfaiture ou pas fortfaiture ?
Ça ressemble à ça. Oui. Euh mais ça ça
m'amène à poser une autre question.
Comment ça
beaucoup plus directe que moi hein ?
Comment ça se fait que
scientifique ? C'est normal.
Comment ça se fait que ça dérive à ce
point ? Alors, il y a un livre qui est
extraordinaire que je conseille de lire,
c'est le traité du pouvoir de Bertrand
Jouvenel.
Dans le traité du pouvoir, il explique
que le pouvoir a toujours tendance à
croître. C'est comme l'entropie ce truc
là. Le pouvoir a toujours tendance à
croître. Ce qu'on voit en Europe, c'est
une structure qui qui se s'approprie un
pouvoir que son statut ne lui donne pas.
Ce qu'on voit en France, c'est que même
totalement impuissant, un président de
la République continue à faire le boulot
d'un premier ministre alors que c'est
absolument pas dans la Constitution.
Donc ce qu'on a derrière ça, c'est une
dérive naturelle du pouvoir qui tend à
croître. Je pense que c'est du devoir
des citoyens de dire la stop, c'est pas
le mandat qu'on vous a donné, c'est pas
pour ça que vous avez été élu. Vous avez
été élu pour remplir un certain nombre
de fonctions, remplissez ces fonctions.
Et quand vous sortez de ces
fonctions-là, si on avait un parlement
qui tenait debout au niveau européen, on
désingré la personne qui sort de ses
fonctions parce que c'est une trahison
pure et simple du fonctionnement de
Mais y le parlement a le même intérêt
que la commission,
c'est étendre étendre leur pouvoir.
Étendre leur pouvoir. C'est c'est le
même intérêt. C'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut que
ce que tu disais
faut couper des têtes.
Non, il il faut c'est pas couper les
tête en changer quelques-unes
certainement. Mais en tout cas il faut
arrê il faut changer de gouvernance, il
faut changer de la manière de
travailler. Il faut changer la manière
de travailler. Il faut revenir comme le
disait Yve autre été et comme on est à
27 bientôt on va être à 31 sans compter
la Moldavie et l'Ukraine ça fera 33. Non
mais là tu au père Noël là quand même.
Je ne sais pas
la Bolaville Ukraine c'est combien le
SMIC en Ukraine ?
Non mais les 30 les les 31 ils sont à
qui parce que les quatre pays
balcaniques ils vont entrer. Donc
les combien les les combien les
balcaniques les
par les quatre pays balcaniques euh ils
vont rentrer. Donc on on on on va être
31 on ne pourra pas comment gérer
l'Union européenne à 31 comme on l'a
géré à 6 ou à 12. Et c'est ça qu'il faut
que les gens comprennent. Et puis enfin
et il faut donner de la liberté.
Couper des têtes, c'est se donner
l'illusion d'avoir un pouvoir. Je veux
dire, ça sert à rien de couper des têtes
qui sont creuses. C'est pas la peine.
Euh je veux dire, le le problème, c'est
de savoir quel est le mode de
fonctionnement. Et le mode de
fonctionnement pour un pays, il est
donné par sa constitution. Pour au
niveau européen, il est donné par les
traités. Et je veux dire, il faut
revenir à ça et appliquer la totalité et
de la Constitution et des traités et pas
imaginer des trucs qui sont pas dedans.
Quand on a un machin en France qui
s'appelle le domaine réservé, je mets au
défi quiconque de me trouver dans la
Constitution où est le domaine réservé.
Simplement, il y a un moment un
président qui a dit que bah ça c'est mon
domaine réservé. Puis après par
jurisprudence,
nomé le ministre de la défense, c'est ça
?
et par jurisprudence. Mais ce que je
veux dire simplement, c'est quand même
pas pour rien qu'il y a des écrits,
il y a des écrits constitutionnel, il y
a des écrits qui sont détraités et ces
choses-là, ils ont un contenu.
Je peux je peux reprendre la parole là
une
? Oui, éventuellement.
Merci. Veu, tu es trop bon. Tu es trop
maganime avec moi ce soir.
Et c'est bien beau de dire il y a CA
faucon, changeons, il faut Bon la
population, elle fait quoi là ? aux
élections, il faut lui donner des il
faut c'est dans les urnes comment ça va
se passer parce que le pouvoir qui
s'étend, il n'écoute plus
le pouvoir
comment on fait pour faire écouter le
pouvoir
il y a différentes différents moyens
d'abord les urnes, le
aurnes,
il y a il y a toutes les formes
d'expression des citoyens. La
manifestation en est une.
La manifestation des gilets jaunes a été
réprimée dans le sang comme dans un état
du tier monde.
Ouais. Enfin, je pas tout à fait quand
même.
Ça s'appelle des manœuvres de
contre-insurrection digne d'un pays du
Tiermonde.
Oui, je partage pas cet avis mais enfin
bon, ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
réprimer les manifestations. Les gens
ont le droit de manifester. Ils n'ont
pas droit de tout casser quand même
hein. Une petite différence mais la
manifestation fait partie des manières
de la manière de s'exprimer. Euh je ne
suis pas un adepte des conventions
citoyennes.
Je peux changer d'avis mais moi je ne
suis pas actuellement un adepte de cela
parce que je je je trouve que c'est pas
un moyen démocratique que de nommer les
gens euh en tirant au sort les personnes
qui pourront y participer.
Je suis pas absolument contre mais enfin
franchement je suis pas je suis je suis
pas fanatique.
Il il faut que il faut qu'il y ait des
partis politiques. Je crois que la vie
politique ne peut pas fonctionner sans
parti politique.
Il faut qu'il y ait des partis
politiques. Actuellement, il y en a pas.
Actuellement, il y en a pas. Moi, j'ai
connu les partis politiques à une
certaine époque. Le parti communiste, on
savait qui c'était. C'était
sa qu'il est financé aussi.
Bon, un sujet je j'étais pas j'étais pas
au Parti communiste, Parti socialiste
que j'ai mieux connu. Je savais ce que
c'était.
On savait comment il se finançait aussi.
Non mais Oui, on on on travaillait dans
ce parti, on travaillait. Il y avait des
commissions, il y avait des gens qui
élaboraient, il y avait une ligne et
cetera. Il y avait le le parti gauliste
qui qui existait également. Sans parti
politique, la vie ne se la vie politique
ne se structure pas. Donc je suis moi
partisan des partis politiques et des
partis politiques forts comme je suis
partisan de syndicat forts.
Tu votes quoi ?
Moi
actuellement je suis dans le désarrois.
Je suis pas je ne suis pas tout à fait
le seul.
Et ben oui,
mais je je je résoudrais plutôt rou
je résoudrai je résoudrai mon problème,
mais je suis euh je je pense qu'on a
besoin de de structures fortes, syndicat
forts, parti politique fort, le
mouvement associatif très important
aussi parce que actuellement c'est lui
qui fait société en France, il y a plus
le Parti communiste, il y a plus
l'église catholique. Il y a il y a il y
a l'islam. Il y a il y a l'islam pour
une partie de la population, pour les
pour pour les les personnes qui euh les
musulmans. Euh mais il faut il faut
qu'il y ait que le que que qu'il y ait
des des lieux où on fasse société, les
associations permettent de faire société
mais encore une fois on ne pourra pas se
passer de partis politiques, on ne
pourra pas se passer de syndicat.
On a remarqué une chose et je te donne
tout de suite la parole. On a remarqué
que le vote auprès du bloc central était
inversement proportionnel au coût de la
calorie.
Tu sais ce que ça veut dire ?
J'ai Non, j'ai pas bien compris.
Bah, ça veut dire que plus l'énergie est
chère, plus le coût de la vie est cher,
plus les gens votent extrêmes.
Oui, ça c'est possible. Ça c'est
possible. Mais il y a pas il y a pas que
ça. C'est c'est pas ça qui lui conduit à
voter aux exè
plus de fo dans les rat, les chevaux se
battent hein. Pardon ? Ma grand-mère
disait quand il n'y a plus de foin dans
les rateliers, les chevaux se battent.
Vraiment
ça c'est c'est vrai un problème plus
général de pouvoir d'achat des couches
populairirees des classes moyennes. Ça
c'est clair.
Pouvoir d'achat qui qui qui a été très
impacté par le l'inflation récemment et
qui n'est pas revenu à son niveau
d'avant 2019
et qui ne reviendra jamais.
Pourquoi pas ? Si j'espère. J'espère. Il
faut de la croissance pour ça. Il y a
pas de croissance. s'il y a pas
d'industrie. Enfin, ça on revient à
notre propos de départ. Donc euh je je
crois mais je pense qu'il y a d'autres
raisons pour lequel il y a les extrêmes.
Je
Yve.
Alors c'est
comment je dirais ça ?
Je suis assez convaincu du fait qu'il
faut des parties mais je suis aussi
convaincu du fait qu'il faut qu'il
travaille.
Oui, travail bien sûr.
C'estàdire il y a un certain nombre de
questions, je veux dire les questions
d'énergie, les questions d'industrie,
c'est des questions qui se traitent pas
aux doigts mouillés, c'est des choses
questions qui demandent de bosser.
Euh et dans l'état actuel des choses,
moi j'aurais dit à mes parents que je je
discuterai avec le parti communiste, ils
auraient été horrifiés dans ma lointaine
auverge. Et je veux dire le PC est le
seul parti à ma connaissance qui ait eu
une réflexion de fond sur ce qui est une
programmation énergétique. On peut être
d'accord ou non avec ce qui est en sorti
mais c'est solide. Euh les autres les
autres j'ai jamais vu.
Et sur ce point je suis plutôt d'accord
avec eux. Oui oui mais tout à fait mais
mais je veux dire ils ont c'est c'est
pas le nucléocrate qui dit ça. Ils ont
fait une analyse des besoins, une
analyse des une analyse des capacité,
une enf c'est bien fait. C'est bon je
vais donner un un autre invers à
l'inverse on a un ministre, je crois
qu'il doit être encore ministre encore
que ça change tout le temps. Donc j'en
sais jamais mais à l'époque où je
m'étais pas encore complètement fâché
avec les gens de Renaissance, j'avais vu
un certain nombre de de députés
et c'était sur les questions d'énergie.
Je leur ai dit à un moment avec excéd
parce que j'entendais une quantité
d'annerie absolument invraisemblable.
dit écoutez c'est pas très compliqué sur
les questions là vous êtes une trentaine
là sur la question d'énergie et une
quinzaine de questions qui sont vraiment
importantes. Vous mettez par deux sur
chaque question au bout de 6 mois vous
serez pas des experts mais ça vous
évitera de vous faire enfumer par le
premier chalon de venu quoi. Grosso
modo. Et un un des députés Renaissance
qui est maintenant ministre m'avait dit
à l'époque "Mais vous pensez bien qu'on
a pas le temps ? Je dois dire que
j'étais sidéré sur quelque chose qui est
à ce point essentiel pour la vie
économique d'un pays d'entendre
quelqu'un qui aspire au plus haute
responsabilité qui les atteint et qui
dit qu'il a pas le temps de réfléchir au
cœur du problème. J'ose espérer que
c'était une plaisanterie. J'en suis pas
sûr.
Il s'appelle Sébastien Lecnu.
Non non non, il s'appelle pas Sébastien
Lecornu. Il s'appelle Roland l'escur. Et
il est formé comme ingénieur
polytechnicien. Donc c'est pour vous
dire que la question c'est pas une
question de formation technique. La
question c'est une question d'intégrité
et de dévouement au sens de l'État. Et
ça je regrette. Moi j'ai des de ce
côté-là c'est des choses qui sont non
négociables. Mais alors toujours est-il
que ce que je veux dire ici c'est que je
pense qu'on a besoin de parties et de
parties qui sont claires. C'est-à-dire
qu'on puisse dire je suis d'accord avec
celui-là, je suis pas d'accord avec
celui-là, je suis d'accord avec telle
partie de tel programme de tel de tel
aspect du programme du parti. et je mets
au défi quiconque de donner une vision
avec un epsilon de cohérence des
déclarations actuelles des différents
partis qu'on a à l'Assemblée nationale.
Et je pense que c'est ça qui exaspère
tout le monde maintenant. Et donc je
pense que c'est vraiment une question de
moi je fais partie des gens qui sont
extrêmement attachés à la démocratie
parlementaire parce que le monde est
complexe est compliqué disons parce que
complexe ça a été dégalvodé. Le monde
est compliqué et ça veut dire que quand
on délègue sa souveraineté à des
députés, on est en droit d'attendre
qu'il passe le temps qu'on leur paye à
pouvoir travailler au fond des choses et
à pouvoir avoir une vision qui est
instruite des différentes questions
essentielles qu'il faut poser. Je pense
que ça n'est plus le cas
et ça je dois dire ça m'agace.
J'onne juste je prends une minute pour
expliquer. Louis a une réunion tuperware
à 20h30 donc on va être obligé de le
lâcher à 20h30. Moi, je voudrais revenir
sur sur les extrêmes parce que je
voudrais que ma pensée soit claire. Je
pense que si il y a des extrêmes, c'est
qu'on ne s'est plus occupé des couches
populaires et des classes moyennes
et que c'est ces personnes le sentent et
qu'elles se sentent délaissées
et que donc elles cherchent des
solutions. Et comme les gens qui sont au
gouvernement ou qui aspirent à y être ne
sont pas ne s'intéressent pas à eux, bah
ils vont voir ce qui s'intéresse à eux.
Et et et je pense que
tout le problème du parti où j'ai été
dans ma jeunesse, le parti socialiste,
c'est qu'il faut qu'il revienne vers les
claves couches populaires. Il les a
quitté par avec le mirage de se dire euh
l'avenir c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt les les classes moyennes
supérieures, c'est celles qui font
l'opinion et cetera. Et je pense qu'il
faut revenir vers vers les couches
populaires. Si si les partis de
gouvernement ne reviennent pas vers les
couches populaires, nous aurons les
extrêmes.
Alors, il y a un autre aspect qui encore
une fois est pas décorrélé de la
question de l'industrialisation.
Je dire une industrie c'est quelque
chose qui crée de la richesse et c'est
parce qu'on crée de la richesse dans un
pays qu'on peut avoir des classes
moyennes, qu'on peut avoir des gens qui
ont un espoir de monter dans la société
et que ces gens-là dès l'instant ils ont
un espoir d'une certaine manière c'est
quelque chose qui induit un vote modéré
un vote modéré à gauche ou un vote
modéré à droite mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui induit vers les extrêmes.
Quand on a une industrie qui se dégrade,
des coups qui explosent, et ben les gens
qui restent, ils se trouvent comme le
dit Louis se trouve laissé laissé pour
compte et ils s'orientent, ils vont vers
les extrêmes et ça c'est quasiment
mécanique. Pas gagner les élections
comme ça. Mais ça veut dire ça veut dire
que la question de l'industrie la
réindustrialisation de ce pays est à la
fois une question essentielle pour notre
économie, pour notre niveau de vie, mais
c'est aussi une question essentielle
pour la bonne santé de nos démocraties.
Je suis entièrement d'accord avec ce
point. Je pense que
Est-ce que tu autorises Louis à parler ?
Ouais,
vas-y Louis.
Non, non, mais je je je suis entièrement
d'accord avec ce point. Je pense que
l'industrie c'est pas uniquement une
question économique, c'est pas une
question technique, c'est une question
politique au au meilleur sens du terme.
Parce que si on veut être capable de
créer les conditions qui permettent aux
citoyens de de se dire que l'avenir est
mieux meilleur que le passé, que leurs
enfants auront un une capacité être à à
monter par rapport à eux, et bien il
faut de l'industrie. Bon, ça
OK. Mais Louis là, tu enfonces des
portes ouvertes là, on est entre nous.
Non non mais je m'enfonce pas des por
c'est c'est la réité il faut
comment ça se fait que le parti
socialiste il ait pas pensé à ça depuis
30 ans ?
Mais ça c'est son problème,
c'est pas le mien. Je ne suis plus je ne
suis plus au Parti socialiste depuis
1992.
Donc il t'en a fallu du temps quand même
hein.
Non, j'ai j'ai quitté au moment de la de
de la de la guerre en Irak.
Ah oui
contre laquelle j'étais.
Donc
contre laquelle j'étais la première la
première guerre en Irak. Et donc mais je
je suis absolument persuadé que le Parti
socialiste a fait une erreur stratégique
majeur.
Ça s'appelle Parti socialiste. Louis en
sortant en sortant en sortant encore une
fois en s'intéressant plus au couche
populaires. Louisi, les patrons, les
patrons de PME, les capitaines
d'industrie, nous on a beaucoup de
petits patrons qui nous appellent, qui
sont en assaut, euh qui nous demande euh
la vision en tant qu'analyste en tant
que prospectiviste, là où on sent les
choses ou des choses comme ça, des
patrons.
Démocratiquement parlant, est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas que les petits patrons et
les grands patrons se mettent ensemble
et disent au gouvernement, "Tu
continues, on va on va t'attraper par
les oreilles, on va te faire comprendre
que ça suffit." Maintenant, tu fais du
bruit avec ta bouche, tu agites tes
petits bras tout le temps, ça fait bien
à la télé, tu prends le contrôle de la
rhthorique, tu prends le contrôle de la
dialectique, tu utilises tes petits
copains journalistes que tu es que tu
mets juste derrière le robinet de
l'information, ça va 5 minutes, mais
quand la réalité elle frappe, c'est ça
va être difficile pour le pays. Est-ce
qu'il faut que les patrons d'industrie,
les petits patrons, je vais pas dire le
MDEF, mais il fasse je sais pas c'est
CME, soit le BDF,
soit l'UTP, mais il faut il y a des
organisations,
faut pas y aller, il faut pas y aller à
leur tirer les oreilles un petit peu
maintenant là, il faut pas sonner la fin
de la presse. Je pense que les chefs
d'entreprise
doivent s'exprimer, plus qu'ils le font,
sur leurs préoccupations et sur les
sujets qui les concernent. Ils peuvent
aussi s'exprimer pour donner de l'espoir
au pays, pour dire que ils sont
eux-mêmes engagés dans des démarches qui
sont des démarches euh positives parce
que eux ils sont ils sont obligés tous
les jours par la par de par par
l'activité de leur entreprise d'aller de
l'avant. Et bien je pense que les
patrons, ils doivent dire ça aussi. Ils
doivent dire ce qui ne marche pas. Ils
doivent dire ce que les
les les les les problèmes que vous
évoquiez de de de
management, j'allais dire de la vie
publique qui qui ne fonctionne pas, mais
ils doivent aussi être porteur de
l'avenir, de l'espoir et pas uniquement
eux, tous leurs salariés. Moi, j'ai une
expérience extraordinaire.
Quand j'étais chez Airbus, on avait une
usine de fabrication de pâ d'hélicoptère
à la Cour Neuve
et
les classes venaient dans cette dans
cette usine pour voir comment on
fabriquait les pes d'hélicoptères.
Et je voyais le le plaisir et la des
compagnons pour expliquer leur boulot
aux jeunes. Et les jeunes étaient
fascinés. C'était des gamins qui étaient
en 4e en 3e et bien ils étaient fascinés
par voir comment on faisait une pâle
d'hélicoptère et et et les compagnons
étaient extrêmement fiers de leur de
leur dire comment ça se fait. Mais ça,
il faudrait le multiplier pour que on
recrée dans ce dans ce pays,
j'allais dire la volonté de progresser,
la volonté du progrès, la volonté
d'avancer. C'est pour moi c'est c'est
absolument décisif. Je le disais, c'est
la volonté de produire, d'être de se
projeter en avant.
On en est pas là aujourd'hui.
Il nous reste il nous reste 5 minutes
avec Louis. Donc je vais lui poser les
deux questions de l'émission puis
ensuite nous on va rester avec
il faut terminer ensemble.
Voulez on va boir des coups.
Ah oui oui oui.
Donc il nous reste 5 minutes les gars.
Je vais juste prendre quelques questions
internet. Alors, vous inquiétez pas, ça
va l'arsener dans les micros. On est bon
parce que j'ai un retour. Hop, on est
bon.
Et on vote pour qui ? On vote pour Jean
la salle. Question internet.
Jean la salle est un homme que tout à
fait formidable parce qu'il est du
sud-ouest et moi je je pense que les
gens du sud-ouest sont des gens
formidables
et en plus en plus personne ne peut être
insensible au caractère empathique de
gens de la salle.
Jean Jean on t'embrasse. Question
internet. La France rétrogarde au 11e en
11e place au classement mondial des
installations de robot industriels avec
seulement 4864 unité en 2024 en baisse
de 24 %. Peut-elle vraiment maîtriser sa
transformation industrielle face à
l'automatisation
pilotée par des géants étrangers comme
Amazon, la Chine, les États-Unis qui
vont licencier massivement au profit des
robots ?
Qui prend la question ?
Ah bah non.
Bah non. Moi je moi je je je crois que
automatiser les usines, faire rentrer
les nouvelles technologies comme
l'intelligence artificielle, la 5G dans
les usines, c'est accroître la
productivité de ces de ces usines, c'est
approître la compétitivité de ces usines
et c'est bon pour l'emploi. On n' jamais
vu de révolution industrielle
sans énergie.
énergie certain mais qui détruisent de
l'emploi. Les canus se sont battu contre
nouveau métier tissé. Ça n'a pas empêché
cette industrie de créer de l'emploi.
Euh quand lorsqu'on a créé la machine à
vapeur, ça a créé de l'emploi. Lorsqu'on
a créé l'électricité, ce qui évoqué Yv,
ça crée de l'emploi. Et je suis
absolument convaincu que si nous sommes
capables d'intégrer ces nouvelles
technologies, d'améliorer la
productivité, nous créerons de l'emploi.
Alors juste
non si je
on va créer d'emploi à condition d'avoir
les formations qui vont pouvoir qui vont
être capables de gérer les changements
d'emploi qu'on est en train de créer.
Absolument.
Je partage c'est la transition qui est
difficile parce qu'on va passer de
certains métiers à d'autres métiers. Il
va falloir assurer la transition.
Je peux gratter 10 minutes ?
Oui.
Tu utilises quoi comme intelligence
artificielle ?
Moi personnellement le chat.
patriote quoi.
Oui, je suis un peu patriotard. Oui, le
chat.
Et dans le business ?
En business,
c'estàd l'intelligence artificielle qui
va remplacer certains métiers,
non, elle va aider les gens à faire à
faire leur métier. Ça va supprimer
certains métiers mais ça va en créer
d'autres. Moi je le le tout le problème
c'est la transition. C'est ce que disait
Yve. Il faut passer du stade A stade B
et il faut que les emplois suivent. Et
et c'est la grande difficulté, c'estàd
qu'il faut que les les gens on leur
donne le temps de faire cette mutation
et d'acquérir les compétences
nécessaires. Yve,
l'intelligence artificielle, les
consommations énergétiques, les
prévisions de consommation énergétique.
Alors sur l'intelligence artificielle,
je dois dire que j'ai la chance d'être
dans une équipe de jeunes qui grosso
modo régulièrement me disent un vieux
machin, regarde ce que peut faire
l'intelligence artificielle. Ce qui est
assez assez intéressant. J'en suis
arrivé à me convaincre que c'est quelque
chose qui permet de faire plus vite ce
qui nécessite pas forcément d'être
intelligent et qui laisse d'avoir qui
laisse plus de temps pour faire des
choses où on a vraiment besoin d'être
intelligent. Euh et donc moi c'est pour
moi c'est un gain de temps euh dès
l'instant où je lui demande pas ce que
ça sait pas faire. Alors je vais donner
juste un exemple que je trouve assez
amusant quand on se dit je vais faire de
de l'intelligence artificielle pour
inventer des nouvelles choses et je vais
le faire à partir de tout ce qui est
publié. Il y a quelque chose qui à mon
avis intellectuellement est assez
choquant qui est que les choses
nouvelles sont souvent construites à
partir des échecs, à partir des choses
qui n'ont pas marché et les choses qui
n'ont pas marché, c'est celles qu'on
publie pas. Donc ça veut dire que de
vouloir utiliser à partir de ce qui est
publié, y compris dans les rapports
d'entreprise. Dans les rapports
d'entreprise, c'est la croix et la
bannière pour que quelqu'un archive un
projet qui a pas marché. et bien de
vouloir euh construire quelque chose qui
est fondamentalement créatif avec la
moitié des informations qui permettent
de le faire qui n'est pas présente, à
mon avis, c'est peut-être de
l'intelligence mais de l'intelligence
d'un cerveau hiplégique. Euh donc encore
une fois, je pense que il faut pas lui
demander plus que ce que ça ne peut
faire, mais il faut pas se priver de ce
que ça peut apporter.
Question internet, c'est bien beau tout
ça, mais qui pour piloter l'avion ? En
attendant, on a les clones politiques de
tout bord qui ont les mêmes intérêts au
fond et rien ni personne ne semble les
arrêter. On en a parlé pendant
l'interview.
Je peux répondre ?
Oui, mais je pense que je je pense que
si pardon
non mais ça va être vite fait. Je pense
que se défausser sur le politique, c'est
un peu comme le dans l'église
catholique, le diable. Le diable, il a
vraiment des vertus parce qu'il permet
d'endosser toute toute notre malice. Euh
je pense que c'est un peu la même chose
de tirer sur le politique en se disant
pas quand même le politique il est élu.
Il est élu par les citoyens. Donc la
première chose qu'il faut c'est que les
citoyens prennent conscience du problème
et envoient au pouvoir délègue leur
légitimité à des gens qui la méritent.
Et s'ils sont pas contents des gens
qu'ils ont envoyé là, bah il faut qu'ils
leur disent et qu'il leur fasse savoir,
ils en envoient d'autres. faut non non
seulement qu'il le le leur disent, mais
éventuellement que eux-mêmes se
proposent pour en faire de la politique.
Moi, je souhaiterais qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale, il y ait plus de personnes
qui ont exercé un métier, c'est-à-dire
qui ont qui ont été je dis pas que tous,
avant c'était la République des avocats
et et maintenant c'est la République des
attachés parlementaires. dans un certain
nombre de cas et bien je trouve qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait une diversité des
métiers présent à l'Assemblée nationale
qui est le le PC tu es capable de faire
monter des ouvriers
il peut y avoir aussi des des d'anciens
chefs de d'entreprise. Il faut que les
gens se mouillent et y aillent.
Il te manque j'en parle d'autant mieux
que je l'ai pas fait. Il te manque
George Marchet
George March George March par exemple.
Question internet. Euh, bonsoir. Comment
envisage comment envisage-t-il la place
des réacteurs de 4e génération à moyen
terme en France pour régler les
questions d'approvisionnement en pour
régler les questions d'approvisionnement
en combustible dans un contexte mondial
de croissance rapide de la demande ?
Alors ça c'est question pour
Oui. Fabine si si
si tu branches sur ce sujet-là, on en a
encore pour 2 heures. Mais grosso modo 7
minutes,
c'est très simple.
Le nucléaire est une manière d'utiliser
une matière qui est par ailleurs
totalement inutile, c'est-à-dire
l'uranium. Euh, il utilise très mal le
nucléaire classique, le nucléaire
thermique utilise très mal l'uranium
parce qu'il utilise qu'un isotope qui
est rare. Euh et donc on est dans une
situation où on a une énergie qui est
limitée dans ses ressources et que toute
la la 5e la 4e génération et la filière
à neutr rapide consistent à utiliser
l'ensemble des ressources en uranium. Et
grosso modo, ça veut dire qu'on se
trouve avec un avec un millénaire de
rien qu'avec l'uranium qu'on a sur qu'on
a stocké, on se trouve avec après à peu
près un millénaire de d'énergie. Et en
conséquence de quoi ? Ça ça suppose
qu'on fait réacteur à neutron rapide et
qu'on ferme le cycle. C'est-à-dire que
on utilise le déchet qui est le
plutonium pour en faire une ressource et
le déchet qui est devenu une ressource
permet d'utiliser l'uranium à qui pour
l'instant était simplement un déchet.
Donc ça c'est la clé de voûte d'un
nucléaire durable. et les écologistes
avaient parfaitement compris que c'était
la clé de wout. C'est pour ça qu'ils
l'ont tué euh et enfin qu'ils ont essayé
pour plusieurs fois de le tuer. Donc je
pense que si on regarde, ils ont ils ont
bénéficié de du soutien de d'un certain
nombre de personnes. Il y a pas des
écologistes. Non mais tout à fait. Mais
bon mais je pense que les personnes en
question c'est Dieu par mon Dieu
pardonneur, il savait pas ce qu'il
faisait alors que les écologistes
savaient parfaitement ce qu'il
faisaient. Mais le nucléaire durable
d'une certaine manière pour moi c'est un
passage obligé parce que quand on voit
la quantité de réacteurs nucléaires qui
se construisent dans le monde et qu'il y
a pas de raison que ça décroise parce
qu'ils sont un petit peu moins
branquignol que nous pour ce qui est de
l'élan et a pas de raison que ça
décroise et on se retrouvera à un moment
et typiquement vers les années 2050 à
peu près vers une tension sur le marché
de l'uranium euh de l'uranium naturel.
cette tension là, si on regarde où
est-ce qu'on produit l'uranium, bah il y
a gros quatre pays, quatre grands pays,
euh le Niger, le Kazakhstan, euh
l'Australie et le Canada. Le Niger, on
peut pas dire qu'on soit bien vu. Le
Kazakhstan, c'est dans une sphère
d'influence qui est pas vraiment la
nôtre. Donc reste l'Australie et le
Canada. Moi, je me dis si on est dans
une situation de tension et que
l'Australie et le Canada ont à choisir
entre fournir l'Europe et fournir les
États-Unis ou la Chine, je pense qu'on
sera pas bien placé. Donc si on veut
avoir une souveraineté au niveau
européen et un forci au niveau français
en terme de ressources et de ressources
énergétiques, c'est un passage obligé.
Je lis une dernière question et pendant
ce temps-là euh Louis prépare sa réponse
sur trois livres recommandés à notre euh
à notre communauté et un conseil pour
les jeunes générations. Je lis la
question pour Yve. Bonsoir. Question
pour monsieur Bréchet, technicien dans
le nucléaire engagé pour servir mon
pays. Je m'aperçois de plus en plus que
sous l'égide de l'amélioration continue,
nous passons un temps fou. à faire tout
sauf notre métier. Suis indicateur
bidon, paralysie de l'action, sous
l'égite de la sécurité. Tout semble être
un prétexte pour faire obstacle à notre
productivité. Question : croyez-vous que
cela puisse être fait à dessin, que ces
politiques industries réelles soient
dictées par des gens qui n'ont pas
d'intérêt à ce que nous soyons
productifs ?
Je pense pas. Enfin, j'ai pas de preuve
que ça soit fait à dessin, mais par
contre, j'ai la certitude que c'est pas
une fatalité.
Louis, trois livres pour notre
communauté.
Trois livres.
Le premier parce que je viens de le
finir, la maison vide qui vient de
sortir, qui risque d'avoir le concours
qui grand concours. Je trouve c'est un
c'est un grand livre. C'est un grand
livre. On on sort pas comme ça
disparant. Un
un second livre, c'est ma lecture de
l'été, l'humeur révolutionnaire.
C'est un historien américain qui a
travaillé qui qui travaille sur la
France et qui a travaillé sur tout ce
qui a dans l'aire du temps a préparé la
Révolution française entre 1750 et 1789.
tous les tous les éléments qui qui ont
constitué l'opinion pour lui permettre
de de d'aller vers vers la révolution
française. C'est c'est passionnant. Et
le troisème livre qui est peut-être le
livre de ma vie, c'est vie et destin de
Vassili Grossman qui est un chef-dœuvre
absolu qui est une presque formidable de
l'évolution de de de
du nazisme, du communisme et Stalingrad,
c'est un livre magnifique.
Oui, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et préparer trois livres. Un
conseil, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. La curiosité,
avoir envie de de voir comment ça se
passe, passer derrière le rideau,
toujours la curiosité.
Yve, trois livres, un conseil pour les
jeunes générations et après c'est
Réunion Tuperware et demain il y a
interview en plus. Donc Yve, trois
interviews euh trois livres, pardon.
Alors, le premier livre c'est Je suis un
homme du 18e siècle, moi ça c'est je le
revendique. C'est un livre que je trouve
extraordinaire de Richard Dunton. qui
s'appelle l'aventure de l'encyclopédie.
L'encyclopédie, c'est un moment unique
où on avait à la fois des gens qui
s'occupaient de parler de la science, de
la technologie et qui était aussi des
gens avec un véritable talent
littéraire. Et c'est été une aventure
menée de main de maître pardro avec des
moments qui sont complètement
recambolesques. C'est vraiment quelque
chose à lire. Un deuxième livre euh qui
est un livre d'espoir. On a beaucoup
parlé de la situation politique. J'ai lu
un livre il y a pas très longtemps que
je trouve absolument admirable qui
s'appelle Cours familier de philosophie
politique de Pierre Manant. Et c'est un
livre qui donne une idée de ce que peut
être la politique. C'est pas un livre de
rêve, c'est un livre d'analyse de la
valeur de la philosophie politique et
ce que peut ouvrait. ce que peut et de
vrai. Euh et c'est un livre extrêmement
sage euh mais extrêmement riche. Et le
troisème livre que je recommanderai,
c'est un livre qui alors là, je viens de
vous parler de ce qui donne espoir en
fonction de ce que ça pourrait être. Le
troisème livre, c'est ce qui permet de
supporter ce que c'est. C'est les
chroniques des choses magnifiques de
Alexandre Vialat qui est un overnia.
C'est des petites chroniques qui ont un
humour absolument dévastateur. Il faut
que vous sachiez qu'Alexandrealat est le
traducteur de Kafka en français et qu'il
était absolument persuadé que Kafka
était un humoriste.
J'ai le même raisonnement avec Bruno
Lemè mais je sais pas si c'est la même
chose. J'ai du mal à le traduire. Un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
Yves.
Alors quand vous êtes dans un champ de
rouine, demandez ce que vous pouvez
reconstruire.
Messieurs Réunion Tuperware,
merci d'être là, merci d'être revenu.
Bonne soirée.
Bonsoir.
Merci beaucoup. Bonsoir.
[Musique]